okay so one reason for ownership is that
it's very difficult to
monetize something without that
ownership and if you can't monetize it
you can't calculate its value and if you
can't calculate its value
you can't use it
or you can't know whether you're using
it efficiently or not well but that
would be the same thing essentially
because if you don't use it efficiently
you're going to have to stop using it
pretty damn quickly
and so
to some degree pricing is the antidote
to the tragedy of the commons that's
another way of looking at it is that so
for example in the in the oceans no one
owns the oceans
at least not past once you get out 200
miles it's free for all essentially and
so the consequence of that is that
everyone is incentivized to take every
goddamn fish as fast as they possibly
can and that's exactly what's happened
and it's because the fish are free
right but they're not because they're a
finite resource and so the problem is we
haven't monitor or a problem a potential
problem is that we haven't assigned um
uh a monetized value to the fish
and so once they're pulled into an
economy they're worth something but out
there free floating it's every man for
himself and so that means that
without private property you know you
could make a case that private property
leads to the despoiling of the natural
environment say okay well what about
those situations where there is no
private property well then you get
instantaneous despoiling of the natural
environment because there's no incentive
to maintain it
[Music]
hello everyone
i'm pleased to have with me today dr
robert p murphy dr murphy has a phd in
economics from new york university he's
a research fellow with the independent
institute and a senior fellow with the
mises institute he's held academic
positions at hillsdale college and texas
tech university he is the author of
choice
cooperation enterprise and human action
which is a modern distillation
of ludwig von mises important treatise
on the austrian school of economics he's
the author of several other economics
books for the layperson as well
including lessons for the young
economist and the politically incorrect
guide to capitalism in addition to his
scholarly work
he hosts the popular podcast the bob
murphy show concentrating on economic
and political issues
thanks very much for agreeing to talk to
me today dr murphy how are you doing
oh i'm doing great and thanks so much
for having me on the show dr peterson my
pleasure a lot of my listeners have
mentioned
their belief that my work is somehow
reminiscent
of
work done in the austrian school of
economics and after reading i didn't
really know anything about the austrian
school of economics after reading the
bulk of choice cooperation enterprise
and human action i understand why
there's an emphasis on value i suppose a
lot of my work is predicated on the idea
that it's not my idea but on the idea
that human beings are goal directed
actors and that much of our motivation
much of our behavior can be understood
in that light profitably understood in
that light so to speak and mises
um
insisted upon the primacy of human
action really as his starting point um
why did you write choice cooperation
enterprise and human action and and and
maybe we'll walk through it i wanted to
talk to you because i
wanted a
two-hour lesson in austrian economics
and i suppose i felt that this was the
fastest way to do it and i could share
my
intellectual endeavor
with all of my audience and so i'm
hoping we can manage that today so let's
go to the book
okay so sure thing and i'm happy to do
it uh let me just mention that before i
forget that i have listened to a bunch
of your lectures as well and there was
one besides what you mentioned the
affinity with you know value and that
connection
you often talk about how people get
feedback from social cues of others and
that helps people regulate their
behavior
and
that's a very let's say hayekian
perspective like when i heard that i
thought oh that's sort of like how the
price system gives producers feedback as
to whether they're using resources
profitably in a socially right
advantageous manner so anyway
well i did have an
economic
argument in mind or an economic analogy
in mind when i formulated that argument
i would say
you know it's it's very difficult for us
to compute our way through live life
because life is so complex and so
uncertain and so multifactorial
and all the factors continually change
and so
in yeah in beyond order in my second
book in particular i stress the role of
responsiveness to feedback as a means of
opening
the individual to the corrective
feedback from a distributed
computational device essentially i mean
each of us are calculating
madly
in an attempt to
minimize catastrophe and
and
pursue some degree of
satisfaction and hopefully pleasure
and we're all doing that independently
and cumulatively that makes for an
incredibly complex computational system
it only makes sense to avail yourself of
the outputs of that system if you want
to orient yourself properly in life
and so i'm i made the case that
well one of the things you want to do
with children for example is to make
them
socially receptive
because that way they can avail
themselves of the computational
resources of the society around them and
keep themselves in sync with other
people and hopefully to some degree with
the natural world i didn't think of that
relationship so okay so let's let's
let's move into the economics field and
and
sure so yes you had asked why did i
write the book so
what it is attempting to do is to take
um so ludwig von mises is a giant in the
austrian school of economics and um
and his magnum opus is called human
action
and it's a it's a masterpiece and that's
really in terms of modern austrian
economics people can read that but
unfortunately it's something like 900
pages long even though he wrote it in
english it's a very germanic formal
style um the vocabulary is difficult and
and he assumes the reader is like a
renaissance man or woman and knows all
lots in various fields and mises just
makes off-hand remarks as if the reader
already knows all these things so what i
tried to do with my book choice was to
take you know the essentials of human
action and make it about 300 pages or so
and they the you know the independent
institute the publisher they told me
make it so that it could be assigned
plausibly to an undergraduate class and
so that's what we tried to do and the
thing in particular i wanted to make
sure the reader got out of it was
knowing
um the austrian theory of what causes
the business cycle because to me in our
times that's the essential
scientific finding of the austrians that
even other free market schools are
missing
well let's start with the but let's
start with the basics so okay how did
mises and and in your book how do you
construe the basics of the economic
system how do you define it define the
individual actors within it
okay so the way mises proceeds is he
says um
that
historically there was the classical
economist people like adam smith you
know when he wrote the wealth of nations
and just the title of that shows
that what the classical school was
focusing on was the production of of
wealth of you know physical things that
people value
and that's what they were focused on and
then there was the so-called marginal
revolution when the austrian school was
born and that happened in 1871 carl
menger was one of the three people
credited with ushering in this what's
called the subjective marginal
revolution in economic thought and that
gave us what's called modern value
theory right and so you could you could
there's different theories about why
something is worth something and one
theory would be that
something has a price be because
it took a certain amount of labor to
produce it took a certain amount of
goods to produce it the price has to
reflect the labor
and the goods
i i
i think it's no
it's not unreasonable to point out that
that would be the fundamental
presupposition of marxist
economists
and then
and then an alternative to that would be
well
actually
if you produce something that no one
wants it doesn't matter how much work
and how many resources went into it its
net price is essentially zero if there's
no market demand and so
the economist that you talked about
flipped that on its head and said well
the price of something isn't dependent
on the nature of the resources that went
into it
it's dependent instead on the demand of
the
population served for that particular
good and then you talk about the
marginal revolution which transformed
that theory
that that pricing occurs at the margins
and that would be something very much
worth explaining
okay yeah sure so let me just so
everything you said is perfectly correct
but let me just some people might have
the misconception that
that the labor theory of value is a
specifically marxist invention which
makes sense because you know marx cares
about the working class and thinks that
the capitalists skim off the workers
but
the classical economist also like like
adam smith you know the heroes of the
free-market tradition also adhered to
what we would call a labor theory or a
cost theory of value and it goes back
i want i think even like aristotle so
the old conception was
if if a stage coach trades for so many
chickens in the marketplace there must
be some quantity that's equal in both of
them you know like there's a like the
market prices are a measuring rod of
something that's in the objects and what
is that and so marx thought oh it must
be congealed labor power or something
like that
and so the the marginal subjectivist
revolution of 1871 realized that no when
when a stagecoach trades for
a gold coin
nobody there's that it's not saying a
stagecoach equals a gold coin it's
saying the person who gave up the
stagecoach valued the gold coin more
than the stagecoach that's why that
person agreed to the trade
and the for the buyer it was the other
way around they valued the stagecoach
more than the gold coin and that's why
they did it so there's no equality going
on
it's a difference in subjective
measurements on the margin so there's
inequality from both parties that just
is lining up differently and why on the
margin
okay so the
the the deal with calling and saying
margin
is um
so you know there's the subjective
element which is like i said it's just
what's in people's heads and then the
marginal the reason it's called the
marginal revolution
is that they realize that any given
exchange
is just
particular units so the word margin
meaning like on the edge like the margin
on a piece of paper so
to exp the famous way to motivate this
is to say you know why is it that
diamonds have a higher market value per
unit than water does because water is
essential for life so you would think
water should have a higher price
but the reason is in any particular
exchange you're not trading all the
water in the world for all the diamonds
if you were then the water would be more
valuable it's just like that gallon of
water versus that diamond and so on the
margin that one diamond can satisfy a
lot more of your needs than that
particular gallon of water because most
people already have enough water to you
know satisfy them so it means in the in
that particular circumstance or under
those particular conditions right rather
than making some claim about universal
value yeah and to give a very trivial
but i think illustrative example too of
just applying this when people go to the
grocery store
you know to say oh uh
but cans of coke are on sale
let me buy some that's a good deal
you don't
empty out your bank account and back the
truck up and get every last can of coke
in this you only buy a certain amount
and then at some point you stop
and so as simple as this is to explain
that you have to reason on the margin
you have to say oh the first can of coke
is worth more to me than
my last quarter and the second can of
coke is worth more to me than my second
last quarter if the price is a quarter
per can but at some point after you've
got 16 cans in your cart you say no no
the 17th can of coke is not worth more
than my
18th last quarter in my you know so at
some point you stop
and so then you're showing you that
you're making decisions on the margin
you're not saying is coke worth more
than a quarter a can
that's that question doesn't mean
anything you mean which how many cans of
coke do i have right now is the next one
worth more than my last quarter
so that's the how the thinking is on the
margin
okay do you what role i mean the the
labor theory of value seems to be all of
these theories of value in some sense
seem to be intuitively obvious although
they're different and so that's strange
that they can all be intuitively obvious
i mean it seems that when you decide to
do something
before you've been able to price it you
you you perhaps do something like an
internal calculation to determine
whether your labor is worth it
is
before before you can ascribe a monetary
value to it you might think well this
seems to be worth doing and maybe you
sort out the pricing later maybe that
accounts for some of the attractiveness
of the labor theory i mean there does
and there does seem to be some
association between the amount of work
done and the and the value of the output
right so the
the classical economists you know they
weren't stupid there was a reason
that they thought that was a good
explanation if you go and read their
writings it's not even that what they're
saying is wrong it's just there's only
so much you can do with it so it's true
in a market where there's a good that's
easily reproduced
and you know we have access to all the
inputs or whatever it's it's true that
if if it were selling above the cost of
production
then more people would produce more of
it and that would push down the price
and it would raise the prices of the
inputs until
you know that huge margin
was wiped away so it is true that for
easily reproducible goods where all the
inputs are available in the long run
the selling price has to be very close
to the price of the inputs it can go on
the other way around if people just
stopped buying it because they didn't
like it anymore
then people would stop making it and the
only reason they would resume making it
is if the price fell so that now it was
affordable to me so
there is that element but then but
there's all sorts of counter examples
like like you mentioned
if just because i put a lot of effort
into something or if we're making a car
and we all tie our left hand behind our
backs so it takes longer to make it we
can't charge more for the same
product because we it took more hours
like that you know the consumer doesn't
care how much time went into it
um and then things like you know a
rembrandt painting or something like
there's there's no way to apply that
logic to explain the market price
of a work of art where the you know
where the artist is is now dead so
there's all sorts of things like that or
if we're just walking in the woods and
we come across
some object that's useful to us and then
we want to go sell it to others
we have no idea how many labor hours
went into it because we just found this
thing
we're not going to have a problem
selling it so part of the problem with
the labor theory of value isn't that
it's outright wrong it's that there are
all sort of there are all sorts of
exceptions to its general applicability
and so it can't serve as a universal
theory of price
and was that also true is that so that's
what like manger and william stan johnny
and leon wall ross the
founders of the you know the marginal
revolution that's what they did they
they showed here's the the exact thing
that explains all market prices and then
the stuff that the patterns of the
classical economist
discovered for certain
scenarios we can also handle in this new
framework but this okay so it explains
everything is it reasonable then to
suggest that
the marginal
utility theory of value is the uppermost
bucket in some sense and then inside
that there's
the theory of utility and inside that
there's the theory of
um labor there there those apply on only
under certain preconditions whereas the
marginal utility theory applies
generally it's more comprehensive
right yes that to it first and foremost
to explain
a market price you can use marginal
utility theory period and then if you
want to say more about particular
circumstances like
why is it that the marginal utility
would tend to be such and such under
these conditions you can invoke the
sorts of things that the classical
economist would have used to explain you
know the price of okay or something okay
so it's it's it's something like a
classic piagetian revolution in thought
i mean when piaget
looked at stage theories
he believed that children develop
cognitive
their cognitive apprehension of the
world in stages and that each stage
would account for the everything the
previous stage accounted for plus a
little bit more
and
the same reasoning has been assigned to
scientific revolutions that
einsteinian physics explains everything
that newtonian physics explained plus a
little bit more so that's what makes it
a better theory and so the same thing
might be said about the
marginal the theory of marginal utility
it has more explanatory power
right yeah and i think the analogy with
relativity compared to newtonian
mechanics is correct that that yes the
classical school they could explain a
small subset of market phenomena
whereas the marginal utility approach
explains everything and it doesn't
anything the classical economist could
explain we can explain in a new
framework but we can also explain a
whole bunch of things that the the you
know the classical conversation well
yeah that's just scarcity and they throw
up their hands and say that's that's a
different thing you know we're not
talking about that
okay so
i guess one of the thoughts that kept
going through my mind and this is not a
critique but
it's i think more the consequence of
being ignorant about the field
is that i kept thinking well why should
why is it that people should care
about this now you make a case for that
in the book and so did mises he he
believed that it was absolutely
necessary for people to be informed
about economic matters and about
economic theory but the reason for that
isn't
self-evident so perhaps you could do us
the favor of explaining why we should
care about this and what what does it
buy us as individuals and as a society
to have our to have an economic theory
and more importantly to have this
particular economic theory let's say
okay great um
so i think
just stepping back the the reason it's
so important and certainly this is what
mises thought
for the general public to at least be
aware of the basics of the findings of
economic science is that politically so
much of harmful government policies
are imposed in the name of helping
disadvantaged groups or you know
avoiding bad things
and that this is why we have these
policies in place
and so if the and they're
either they don't help or the bad things
that are allegedly being solved by these
policies are actually being caused or
exacerbated by those same policies okay
so you cite keynes
john maynard keynes in the book and
and you say it
the quotation goes something like those
who care nothing for economics are
generally the slaves of some defunct
economic theory and so the proposition
is
we make decisions based on our economic
theories whether we know it or not and
it's better to have the theories laid
out explicitly and appropriately so that
we make our decisions consciously
rationally and and with as little error
as possible that's basically the
rationale for developing some expertise
in this area
right exactly that and also
so if um for example like something like
quantum physics
the general public doesn't need to know
that or even believe in that in order
for your computer to work you know i
mean they can just go by the computer it
works or it doesn't but with economics
it is important i would argue and mises
would argue for the public to at least
know the basics because
like something like minimum wage laws
if mises is right then that actually
makes it harder for
teenagers with no job skills to get
hired and so if the public is supporting
a hike in the minimum wage to 15 an hour
in the u.s thinking this is going to
help young people
well no that's actually hurting a lot of
them so things like that where let's
walk through that just as a practical
example before we go back to the to the
general outline
so yeah the democrats have been pushing
at at least on the on the edges let's
say
they've been pushing for a 15 an hour
minimum wage
and
people object to that for various
reasons now on the face of it it seems
like it would be a nice thing if
people who were
fated to
toil away in minimum wage positions had
a living wage of let's say 15 an hour
which is hardly um
the income of a tycoon and you can
understand that
people who have some sympathy for those
who are relatively dispossessed would
just as soon see them
thriving economically and then you can
also see that it seems mean-spirited on
the surface of it to object to such a
thing because it's easy to say well what
is it you don't want poor people to have
a living wage which is the the instant
black and white objection that emerges
when any such discussion takes place
now
is it would it be a proposition of the
austrian school
that
instituting a minimum wage of that sort
would be an error and it even for the
people it purports to serve and if so
why and how confident can you be in that
criticism
okay so
great question the um so strictly
speaking i should be clear the austrian
school as such
is value free you know so it's a it's an
objective positive
statement of you know facts about
reality so it can't the austrian
economics per se can't say the minimum
wage
hike is good or bad it can just say
if what the consequences like this is
what happens and so okay okay
um so uh
what
it can we can certainly say is
workers
if their
productivity
is below 15 an hour if you know by the
employer hiring them if they're not
increasing revenue to the firm
if we've put aside the issue of how much
they get paid for the moment if they're
boosting the firm's revenue by less than
15 an hour
then if there's a loss and you have to
pay this worker at least 15 an hour well
then the firm's necessarily losing money
if they hire that person
so to the extent that you think
employers
are profit-seeking and aren't hiring
workers out of charity but are doing it
because it makes a smart business move
then by well we could also say that that
because it makes them able to do it i
mean if i'm making 40 000 a year i can't
afford to pay someone 50 000 a year
whether i want to or not it's just not
within my power
and so is the proposition that
there's a relationship between
supply of jobs like that and
their
their wage such that if you increase the
minimum wage to 15 an hour you
necessarily delimit the number of jobs
that are going to be produced because
because of because of the problems that
you're describing
um
well certainly you can say if you put on
the caveat other things equal right and
so and that's how all these things go so
it could be in chronological time that
it just so happened there was a
technological innovation that somebody
invented some new
tool
and now even when you hire a 17 year old
with no job experience you put this tool
in their hands and they're creating so
much product
like they're you're making an extra 30
an hour by hiring them so if that just
so happened to be invented right when
the minimum wage hike happened
the data would not show a drop in in
employment right but the idea is that's
because there was some exogenous shock
but the the claim is other things equal
yes if you make it artificially more
expensive to hire
some factor input
firms will tend to hire less of it
right just saying something so let me
throw objections to that your way and
tell me what you think um because this
is a pretty crucially important issue so
um maybe i could say well wouldn't firms
merely
reduce the amount they're paying their
other employees the the more highly paid
employees by a fractional amount to
increase the wages pushed down to the
bottom and thereby compensate
by what would essentially be something
like an inter internal tax i mean these
systems are so complex that
there's a theory that
we outlined the theory in the austrian
school about at least to some degree
about why producing a minim wage hike
would delimit jobs but
there's a big difference between how a
system works in reality and how it works
in theory and so
what do you do you think that the
propositions put forward by the austrian
school are of sufficient integrity
that predictions about the consequence
of something like a minimum wage height
can actually be made with some degree of
accuracy rather than merely
being theoretically consistent
but right okay so great question um let
me first just
use a quick analogy or not analogy but
another example
when progressives want businesses to
emit less carbon dioxide
one of the go-to policy measures is a
carbon tax
so in that realm
you know
most people on the left you know they
want other measures too but
when you say hey if we put a 100 a ton
tax on carbon
they don't just start making up all
these reasons why firms don't want to
save money and no no they'll still use
just as much carbon as before they'll
just pay less to other things to come up
with the money
it's all straightforward oh yeah or if
if you want to get people to not smoke
as much what do you do let's put a
really big tax on cigarettes that will
make people so okay so all these other
areas people respond to incentives but
for some reason with labor
the same firms that are money grubbing
and all they care about is jobs and
they'll outsource factories to indonesia
to save two cents on labor
if you make teenagers in the u.s twice
as expensive by more than doubling the
minimum wage no it's a right-wing lie
that they'll hire fewer workers so i'm
just noting the income
okay so your proposition is that
the same people who formulate these
theories
allow make an exception in the case of
those exceptions they want to see but
they abide by the general principles
that the uh that the austrian school
holds or that the marginal theory the
marginal the theory of marginal utility
proposes in other situations used carbon
tax as an example right
so so the basic proposition is if you
make something more expensive firms will
be incentivized to use less of it right
and even in the context of just labor
again to say oh if it turned out that
they ran the numbers and they could shut
down the factory in the u.s lay off all
those people and open the factory and
you know indonesia
and save
a buck an hour
most people love to say oh of course the
money grows capitalists would do that
but yet when you double the price of u.s
teenage labor all of a sudden no they
don't care about money the the employers
so
okay so let me ask you a personal
question yeah and let's let's jump
outside the realm of theory for a minute
do you per
i mean i i understand the attraction of
coherent and powerful explanatory
theories
you know and but i always balance that
against the terrible complexity of the
real world right and so do you believe
that
then that
instituting a minimum wage hike
would in fact be detrimental to the poor
or do you think the system would be
flexible enough to adjust to that and
that the net benefit would be positive
just i understand the theoretical
prediction but there's always margin of
error right right and i also understand
the objections you laid to it you're
absolutely right that people assume well
the corporations will maximize their
profit-seeking behavior and why wouldn't
they do that in the case of the minimum
wage but but still you know the the the
ethical argument for cranking up the
amount of money that poor people are
paid for doing minimum wage jobs it's
really quite compelling emotionally and
so
you have to be pretty damn certain of
your first principles to say well hold
on there you're actually going to do
people more harm than good and so
are you confident enough in the way that
these theories lay themselves out so you
do believe that that would be bad policy
even for the very people that it
purports to serve
okay okay so
ethically i'm against it because i
believe in property rights and i don't
think the government has the the
authority to tell people
you know oh you if you're gonna hire
someone you have to pay them this amount
like as long as they're voluntary
contracts you know and it's not a
six-year-old who doesn't know what
they're agreeing to
you know i i don't think the government
has the right to to do this so so for
that reason i would never be in four but
in terms of just the economic impacts
i think
for a a modest minimum wage check so i
think everybody agrees if they set the
minimum wage at three hundred dollars an
hour that would be devastating
right that that would come in the
account right so everybody agrees if you
did it too much all the stuff the
austrians and the chicago school types
are warning about would be true so all
we're quibbling about is could you do it
a little bit such that the net benefits
right exactly exactly
so
i i do agree i mean they have raised the
minimum wage in the past and it's not
that all of a sudden you know no
teenager can get a job anywhere but it
is true empirically
that
unemployment rates among
you know young people are much higher
than the general population right and so
this you know is partly to explain why
that would be um it's so i think you're
right in practice
there are other considerations that come
into play and that's i mean it could all
ultimately work through the issue of
productivity that for you know small
minimum wage hike
the firm like a mcdonald's franchise is
probably not just going to lay off
everybody because that would be bad for
morale um but
i think what is true is knowing minimum
wage hikes are on the horizon
they have revamped their operations to
have more kiosks to have you know right
so now instead of having eight teenagers
on each shift they've got one 35 year
old manager who's got you know the thing
taking orders from drive-through they've
got the machines that are optimal they
just put the drink there and hit the
size and the machine fills it up they're
running you know okay
so we can say it was true all right so
we could say with some certainty then
that there's a price to be paid for
increasing the minimum wage and the
price is that minimum wage workers are
more expensive and will therefore and
therefore that will incentivize the
search to replace them in some manner
right and right and how much they're
replaced well that's not easy to
calculate but the incentives are then
push in that direction yeah and i would
also i mentioned too that there's
winners and losers i would i would say
so it's i can't make a blanket statement
oh this is necessarily bad so yeah if
they raise the minimum wage when the
dust settles there will be
workers who are earning 15 an hour who
in the alternate timeline would have
only been earning 8.50 an hour let's say
but
there's also a lot of workers that never
had a job in the first place that maybe
would have gotten a chance to get hired
and never so that okay so that's
interesting because that means that in
some sense there's a more there's a
hidden moral hazard there
which drives that sort of behavior
because you can imagine this scenario
it's like
every single person who has a job that's
a minimum wage job who gets a boost to
15 dollars an hour is going to be very
happy about it and all those people who
don't have jobs won't know that that's
the reason why
right
right they might
you know attribute it to
race well they could attribute it to 10
things right to 15 they're not
necessarily going to point to that
decision and say well it's that specific
decision that means that i don't have a
job at all right and i should also
mention too um
i i know i actually know the canadian
data better because i've done some work
for the fraser institute up there but
it's
um
it's called a low-income cut-off
threshold is like the canadian
government's measure of poverty you know
like households that are above or below
poverty and
these aren't the exact numbers but it's
in the 80s percent where 80 of the
people who make
minimum wage in canada are in households
above that
poverty threshold and vice versa 80 of
the people who are in households that
are below the poverty threshold make
more than the minimum wage
so it's not correct to think of minimum
wage earners as like single mothers who
are struggling with kids at home it's
like
suburban teenagers who are home from
college for the summer who are going and
working at mcdonald's for a summer job
like that's you know the more
prototypical minimum wage worker it's
not
some you know blue-collar person who
another thing too just to mention
most people earn more than the minimum
wage so the very crude notion of power
bargaining and the employer has all the
bargaining power and that's why we have
to if that world view were true just
about everyone would earn the minimum
wage and yet most people earn more and
so once you say well why is that well
it's because of competition and the
people's skills are 20 an hour they're
going to get paid more than 725
you realize okay so it's really
important actually to figure out who is
it that's only qualified for a minimum
wage job because that also drives the
narrative of the utility of of raising
the minimum wage right and and your
claim is that it's mostly people from
households that are above the poverty
line they're not people they aren't the
minimum wage earners aren't the people
upon whom
multiple children are dependent
typically right and and so that's why
like just to give you an example it
could be a perverse thing if to
significantly raise the minimum wage
thinking
you're helping poor people could end up
largely raising wage rates of
middle class workers but making fast
food more expensive
for a lot of poor households that that's
just you know the moms coming home from
work and she runs to mcdonald's to get
something for the kids and now
some of the price you know some of the
minimum wage hike got passed through to
make that food more expensive whereas
she already was earning more than the
minimum wage right that reminds me of
some of the controversy that surrounded
walmart because walmart pays its
employees a relatively low wage but they
also provide food
at below what the market
was was charging for for groceries basic
groceries at that point and so
you could make the case that they were a
net benefit to people who were in
poverty because they drastically
they lowered they materially lowered the
cost of groceries so it depends on
whether you look at the wages they paid
or well and they also provided jobs for
that matter and i'm not necessarily
trying to you know provide a defense for
walmart i'm just pointing out that
there are multiple factors that need to
be taken into account when you're
analyzing the consequences of such
decisions
so so i was thinking too about the your
book
philosophically
again trying to solve the problem of why
this is important
no
there is a philosophy that goes along
with each economic school and the
philosophies in many ways
have a pronounced effect on the nature
of the public debate i mean right now
we we seem to be falling prey
to a pretty intense ideological battle
between
those who claim that our social
institutions are functionally
functionally predicated on the
expression of arbitrary power
which is
in my view some in some manner related
to the labor theory of value and the
notion that capitalists skim off the
extra value which is something we should
return to and there's an entire critique
of the structure of society that goes
along with that now mises
predicated his ideas and that this is
partly why these works are
philosophically important and ethically
important mises predicated his work on
different a priory principles so he
believed that people were capable of
um
free action that was our determining
characteristic and that we banded
together cooperatively
to maximize the
what would you say to to maximize the
consequence of our free action and it's
not it's not a theory that's predicated
on the expression of arbitrary power
yeah so uh and this even kind of ties
back to what we're just talking about
the minimum wage debate that i think the
fundamental divide between people like
me who are warning about the negative
consequences and people who are saying
no no the firms will just if you force
them at gunpoint to pay more they will
because they got buckets of money
and why i was saying well that's why
it's if that's the person's world view
where they think it's all just a matter
of the the you know the employers have
all the power if you're a starving
worker you got to just accept whatever
they give you
if that were really the full story or
most of the story
everybody should be earning the minimum
wage and yet most people are earning
more and so that you so that shows no
it's really not just about
bargaining power it's if if your labor
time
produces 20 an hour of stuff for your
employer
in a market economy you you might not
get paid 20 but you're not going to get
paid 7.25 because somebody else could
come along and offer you 10
and you would take that offer and
they're still you know they're making
the gap so
um so yes like likewise here the the
marxist conception
i mean there was lots of things wrong
with it but but yeah mises thought no if
you study economics and just see
how is it like why when you study why
would why would an employer hire workers
in the first place
and it's not out of generosity it's
because the worker by adding the
operation
the firm makes more money
but then once you realize okay that's
why so if a worker
can boost your revenue by a certain
amount well other firms want that too
and that's as long as there's
competition
that you know that worker's gonna get
paid accordingly
right and so hypothetically what happens
is as that sorts itself out is that the
managers and the executives and the
entrepreneurial types who are providing
employment
get paid for their managerial
administrative and entrepreneurial
ability in organizing the firms and the
workers i mean not that there's a clear
distinction which is something else you
point out there's not a clear
distinction between worker and manager
worker and entrepreneur
but in any case
the workers pay the entrepreneurs and
the managers for providing the structure
within which they labor essentially
rather than the
managers and entrepreneurs skimming off
the excess labor of the
of the worker and you know and that
distinction between worker and manager
the fact that that distinction is not so
clear is also
of paramount importance i think because
it's very difficult to categorize the
world into oppressors and oppressed if
the categories of oppressor and
oppressed aren't so clear to begin with
right yes you hit on a bunch of things
there so yeah mises was i think one of
the better economists in stressing that
yes we have these i think he called them
catalactic functions meaning like you
got your entrepreneur your worker your
landowner your capitalist and those are
sort of ideal types that we can but he
was saying yes in the real world every
action is entrepreneurial so even a
worker who takes a job with this firm
and you would say oh that's not
entrepreneur well no it was because the
worker had to
forecast the future and say
do i want to be with this firm or maybe
i can go with this startup over here who
maybe is right so they're taking they're
taking a risk right because in some
sense they're purchasing a career
and so they have to analyze the general
marketplace and decide well first of all
where they're going to get best value
for their money but they have to look
into the future and say well is there a
future with this firm and so it's micro
entrepreneurial in some sense because it
only determines the course of their
career and maybe their family's
well-being moving forward so it's a
difference of scale rather than type
right so just like you know some
brash
startup person going to you know outside
funders to say hey can you put money
into my new
software firm
and you know the capitalists are
wondering gee do we want to risk and
invest in this everyone knows that's an
entrepreneurial decision but by the same
token yeah if they go and get a bunch of
programmers and say come work with us
don't go work for google or whatever
work for us because we'll give you
stock options and you know we can't pay
you anything right now again so that
it's like you were saying these
everybody has to be entrepreneurial in a
sense and mises talked about that to go
back to what you're saying you were
right too about
the notion that oh it's the capitalist
skimming off the workers
because it there is a certain
plausibility to that that there's a
sense in which well gee who makes the
cars well the workers go into the
factories and they're using their hands
and whereas the you know the the fat
cats are just sitting getting their
dividend checks looking at the stock
price they're not making the cars
so there is this sense that it's it's
the workers who are making everything
and so why don't they get to keep the
fruits of their labor
but this goes back to bombar who is like
a second generation austrian
he pointed out that it's the time
element that in a sense really the
workers when they get paid their wages
are getting in advance
on what their labor is ultimately going
to bring down the road and so he was
saying you know workers if they wanted
to they could just
form together and they could build
everything and sell it down there no
one's stopping them from doing that but
they want to get paid right front well
they may well they may also be stopped
from doing that because they don't know
how to do it i mean
again there's an intuitively obvious
uh phenomenon at stake there that you
described which is that you know where
the rubber hits the road
is the motion of hands
and when you build something well that's
that's the sort of point at which the
thing manifests itself is the operation
of hands but to say that what hands do
what manual labor does
is the only form of labor is to
completely
eliminate the notion that abstraction
is useful and also laborious and that
would mean that thought itself is of no
utility and that abstraction itself is
of of no consequence
and that seems i mean that's an
extraordinarily primitive theory of
labor to think that thought itself isn't
labor given that we know i mean and we
have to decide if we would accept this
proposition
thought is a labor multiplier otherwise
why bother with it right
right so so if you're good at thinking
you think you think up a more efficient
way of doing something and maybe that's
your managerial um what would you say
contribution
and that's not a matter of exploitation
that's a matter of providing a structure
in which manual labor can be done in a
manner that's more competitive and so
that enables people to hire other people
and it's absolutely ridiculous not to
give
people at all levels of the abstraction
hierarchy
they're due with regard to labor i don't
understand why marx was able to get away
with that like is it is it just the fact
that
it's so obvious where the rubber hits
the road it's so obvious that when
you're working with your hands that
that's work
that that obviousness just overrides
other more abstract considerations more
detailed considerations
um
i'm not sure
if i might just emphasize though because
you made a great point there and just
drive it home for people right so it's
the the fact that the that that factory
is sitting there someone had to make
that decision and that's something that
mises you know focused on with the
socialist calculation debate that i'm
sure we'll get into later in this uh
discussion
but people just take it for granted the
factory is just sitting there and the
workers right you're right show up and
they have all these tools that somebody
you know henry ford or whoever like came
up with the idea of the assembly line
approach to mass producing things like
that someone had to invent that and that
you know and so you're right right and
so you might think henry ford thought
that up in 15 seconds and so the labor
theory of value falls apart pretty damn
hard there because right that's such a
stunning
um technological advancement that the
segregation of labor into its
constituent elements
and it also enabled ford to pay his
workers much more than workers had been
paid previously and he was on board with
that for all his other flaws
he wanted to pay his workers enough so
they could buy what they were producing
so and you could call that
an enhanced form of selfishness i
suppose but it worked out quite well for
the workers and so you do get these
situations where revolutions in thought
produce something of almost incalculable
value and and no labor theory
well any labor theory any theory of
economic value that can't take that into
account is severely flawed
but it still doesn't account for why
it's so damn um attractive yeah and i do
want to come to it but but just another
thing too to consider it also explain or
to just merely explain everything but oh
it's the workers produce everything and
everyone wants to skims off the top
but why is it though that so many
people around the world are desperately
trying to get into
you know advanced country like you know
first world economies let's call them
it's because
an average hour of labor in bangladesh
is not worth as much as it is in the
united states
and so there is something about the fact
that the infrastructure in the u.s or
canada or you know in europe
labor's more productive there than it is
in other places on the globe
so it's you know there clearly is more
to the story than just oh the cat well
and then you know that also raises a
question too is just exactly what
constitutes that productive
infrastructure and a lot of that is
actually conceptual
right because we don't know for example
how much the idea that each individual
is of sovereign value is worth
economically but it looks like it's
worth a lot because cultures that are
predicated on that presupposition
tend to be incredibly productive
economically in cultures that aren't
don't
and so
we can see that abstractions of the sort
that make up the philosophical basis for
economic theorizing actually determine
the economic course of the country and
all the individuals within it so so
let's go back to first principles again
what i'd like to do
if we can manage it is to contrast say a
radical leftist view of economic
function and individual psychology with
the austrian school of economics so this
is going to be difficult but maybe we
can manage it so
we we kind of delved into the labor
theory of value um versus the marginal
utility theory of value and then we took
a bit of a foray into the idea that well
mere you can't easily subdivide people
into manual laborers and those would be
the oppressed class and those who skim
off the top because well we should also
point out that even manual labor takes a
certain amount of abstraction and
intelligence
and
i'm saying that in no
no means whatsoever to be denigrating we
don't have robots that can bus tables
for example because bussing tables
actually turns out to be an incredibly
complex cognitive task
and requires a fair bit of
organizational ability to do efficiently
especially under a high load
and so okay so we've talked about um
we've talked about the theory of
marginal utility and the idea that
where labor resides is not so obvious
and the notion that those higher in the
hierarchy are just skimming is that
unsustainable proposition
but there's other fundamental
differences between let's say the
marxist viewpoint and
and the viewpoint of other economists
including the austrian school so let's
delve into those notion of the person
for example
so
marx presumed that our consciousness was
determined by our society right that we
were downstream from society in some
sense and that's
not a proposition that mises was
particularly fond of
right so
um
i i think i can you know at some point
i'm going to reach the limits of my
knowledge of the marxist worldview but i
think i can safely say
that marx thought the material forces of
production
were the the prime mover in history and
so
um you know you had
slavery in ancient times and then they
gave rise to feudalism and then that
gave rise to
capitalism or mercantilism let's say and
then capitalism and then the next stage
would be socialism and communism and
that he said each stage you know had to
develop
to its fullest potential and then it
would burst asunder the next one and
then at each stage the intelligentsia
would come in
and give an ideological superstructure
to justify
the current system
but it was you know the the productive
forces were the driving thing and then
the the idea people came in to just you
know make up a story to explain right
now and this just and the story was to
justify the exploitation that was part
and parcel of skimming off the excess
label right right but that isn't how
mises looked at it is that people didn't
band together to exploit each other
right this is crucially important right
because
you're the criticism that's directed at
patriarchal structures let's say is
predicated on the idea that they're
fundamentally exploitative and that the
relationship between people is one of
power and the implication of that
especially if it's arbitrary power the
implication is that anybody who occupies
anything but the lowest tiers in a given
organization is in consequence an
oppressor and and and but that
mises insisted that people banded
together for purposes of cooperation and
multiplication of effort and that's a
completely different view so can you can
you provide some justification for that
sure so
the starkest contrast though with mises
responding to that marxist worldview is
he thought that no ideas are
the primary motivation that you know
human action starts always with a
thought you know people have a a goal
and they use their reason to you know
choose a means to try to attain it they
might fail but that's what purposes
behavior is that's what he meant by so
we're rational sovereign actors right
and we're trying to chart our own course
right and so for him to explain for
example you know why is it that
it went from feudalism to
the industrial capitalist age
mises would say it's because ideas of
individual sovereignty and you know
people have rights and
for various historical reasons in
western europe that emerged whether it
was because of christianity or just the
squabbling and the terrain but the idea
that
you know
the king
can't come into your house you're the
castle you know your house is your
castle like notions like that mises
argued came out of western europe
earlier than other places and that's why
they
you know took over the world basically
like that that was the reason and so
then scientifically or empirically why
you know why did why was that idea so
potent or powerful it's because of what
you're saying that mises thought it just
so happens to be the case that human
labor
when you work cooperatively gets
magnified many-fold that if we special
instead of everyone growing their own
food making their own clothes and
everything being their own okay so
there's an attractive there's an
attractive quasi-religious notion as
well
okay so here's what we do
i'll tell you a little story
about this i went and stayed at an
airbnb out on the coast of british
columbia one year and it was this nice
little cabin perched on this on the
shore of this idyllic island
um it was a kind of a log cabin quite
primitive but very
very beautiful in a beautiful local and
the people who owned the place were from
europe and they were back to the land
types so you know night the 1990s
equivalent of hippies and they believed
that
everyone would be better off if they
were self-sufficient and and that they
would be more psychologically healthy if
they returned to the land and so they
bought this place
well
they were trying to be self-sufficient
and grow their own chickens and raise
their own chickens you don't really grow
them
but to raise their own chickens and
plant their own vegetables and and so
forth and what they soon discovered was
that that was
unbelievably difficult
life
that they were
struggling every second to stay afloat
financially and that being
self-sufficient especially on an island
which is a place that poses its own
complications especially in a harsh
climate they were completely trapped and
they couldn't sell their property for
anything near the market value the value
that they had purchased it for and so
their move back to the land was a
complete bloody catastrophe and so well
i want to tell that story because
do we have these romantic notions you
know that we should all be
self-sufficient and
and and that everyone would be better
off
individually in their family in their
town in their states if we were
self-sufficient
but
there's a different idea which is that
we're better off trading with someone
generally speaking even if we're better
at everything
we do than they are at anything they do
and so that's a really crucial point and
so maybe i could get you to elaborate on
that like
we're rational people we don't band
together to tyrannize each other we band
together to maximize our productivity
and we do that to stave off the
catastrophes of nature let's say so that
we have enough to eat and enough to
drink and we don't die from some bloody
miserable disease
that's where the tyranny is in our
subjection to our vulnerability we band
together to maximize our productivity
why does that work
and why is that justifiable in in terms
of assessing the nature of our social
institutions
okay sure and again just to drive home
for mises how critical this was because
for him that was the basis of
civilization that's why
we we need to have
property rights we need to have you know
rules of social order you can't go
around killing people you would
ultimately say because
we civilization you know our standard of
living
rests on the fact that we all specialize
in what we do best produce way more
of our thing than we need personally and
trade it with others and so if every you
know certain people specialize in our
farmers and they grow away more food
than they need
and sell the rest of others and some
people just make a bunch of sweaters way
more than their family needs to wear and
they sell it some people just make a
bunch of cars way more than they're
going to drive and they sell it we all
end up with more food sweatshirts
because once you build one car building
the second one is a lot easier right
it's a lot easier right so so yeah
there's a few
reasons to try to understand why is it
that specialization
magnifies the productivity yeah well
let's walk through that okay so there's
a proposition specialization maximizes
productivity and then trade is of
benefit to all sure okay so let's
justify that from the first person i'll
give you some obvious
reasons so one is people have different
abilities and so you know some people
are just
like a big burly guy is going to be
better as a coal miner than some dainty
woman right and and so things like that
are obvious okay certain regions around
the world just are more hospitable right
you're going to grow more oranges in
florida than you are in alaska it
doesn't you know that's just so clearly
the people in florida should specialize
in growing oranges and people so we can
capitalize on the unequal distribution
of productive resources by trading right
right instead of trying to eradicate the
inequality we can capitalize on the fact
that it exists which is in a sense is
something that eradicates it and
you know what would you say practically
speaking
and that's important to note too because
you know we have this idea and i think
it's deeply rooted in our moral
intuitions that everybody should be
equal it's like well wait a second we
trade on our inequality
so that's kind of interesting you're
better at something than i am at
something let's say
and that's an inequality and and you
might even say well you became unjustly
better at that than i did you know for
historical reasons but the fact of the
matter is that inequality exists so
let's try to address it well one
way of addressing it would be for me to
get as good as you are at that thing but
the other way would be for me to do what
i'm good at for you to do what you're
good at and for us to trade
and then if we have money well we can
transform
the value of our labor into something
that's universal and that is an
equalizing force in and of itself
right yeah that's all certainly true um
just another quick one though is
even if people had similar aptitudes
up front like two people who are
identical in all respects if one of them
went into studying brain surgery and one
of them went into studying
chemistry
30 years later when you check in on them
the one person is going to be way better
at doing brain surgery and the other
person's going to be way better at you
know identifying new chemical compounds
right so because we have finite
resources each of us because we have
finite time
that means that we can't be as good as
everyone can be at everything ever
and so we end up specializing in
something so that we have a comparative
advantage but that's it's not see
the language here and you said mises is
very careful with his language so let's
be very careful with our language if i
study for 30 years it isn't exactly that
i have a comparative advantage over you
it's that i comparatively have something
to offer you
right because advantage implies that
i've
taken something from you in some sense
or now i can hold something over you you
know because you say taken advantage of
someone
but it isn't that it's now that i'm
bringing something to the table that you
actually desire
and so that's not an advantage i have
it's something that i have to offer
that's and if i have any sense i've
picked something that i have to offer
that i know other people want
and so there's a kind of altruism that's
built into that specialization now okay
so i'm going to take it one step
sideways here too from a marxist
perspective now marx also said that
we were alienated that specialization
alienates us from our labor
and you know there's some truth in that
because well here's another example
when i was a kid
16 or 17 i worked at this lumber mill
plywood mill
and it was probably built in the 40s so
it was kind of a dark satanic mill you
know to use the poetic phrase and it had
a pretty hierarchical structure the
foreman
exerted power over the workers and you
know we had 15 minute breaks but it took
10 minutes to get to the break room and
back and so it was pretty regimented it
was classic labor versus manager
situation for what it's worth was
definitely noisy in this place so you
had to wear headphones all the time and
my job was to stand at the end of this
platform
um facing a machine that was about two
blocks long that was basically a natural
gas furnace and i flipped these
pieces of plywood sheathing onto a
conveyor belt and filled the conveyor
belt and it would move into the furnace
and go down the two block
journey through the furnace and be dry
and then my friend who worked on the
other end would take these off and so it
was really it was alienating labor right
i would do that 8 to 16 hours a day
depending on whether i was working
overtime and all i was really doing was
grabbing a piece of wood and flipping it
pushing it forward right and so it was
hot and dusty and all of those things
and now and then the machine would jam
and burst into flames and the whole
plant would fill up with smoke and steam
and then we could climb on top of the
plywood stacks and have a nap and so
that was sort of like the holiday but in
any case
it did give me some sense of what it
meant to be alienated from my labor
there had been guys there guys there who
had been there for like 20 years doing
this job and i thought well that would
just drive me stark raving mad
and so
that alienation theory
i mean how do we deal with that because
the problem with specialization is that
well you have to sacrifice all the other
things you might be to do this one
narrow thing now i know that opens doors
like if you become an expert at
something
you go through a narrowing process while
you're being an expert and then the
world opens back up but
i mean is it
how do you deal with the
or or does the austrian school of
thought deal with the fact that
specialization requires a particular
sacrifice is it the proposition just
that it's
it's worth it compared to the
alternatives
yeah before i forget let me just mention
you hit the nail on that when you when
used a comparative advantage a few
minutes ago and you said that
even if one person or historically it
was done in terms of nations trading
even if one country was better at
producing everything
its people would still have a higher
standard of living if it's specialized
and what it was really good at
and then traded with some other nation
and so david ricardo was credited with
that so that's so you're right that and
why is that because that's that's subtle
and not easy to understand a way to a
more colloquial illustration would be
um
like a doctor
who can do a better job taking people's
blood pressure and weighing them and
writing down on a piece of paper with
their blood pressures and weighing them
and asking them what brings you in today
it would be a waste of the doctor the
doctor shouldn't do that doctor should
hire other people
you know nurses or whatever to
to do that basic information so the
doctor can just focus the time on what
the doctor can do or so he should
constant he should concentrate on
whatever it is that
he's
that other people are least likely to be
able to do right right or so that that's
kind of a general rule so you should
concentrate on what's of general value
but
what other people are least likely to do
or you know other examples are able to
michael jordan is very athletic he could
probably cut his lawn faster than the
neighborhood kid but michael jordan
shouldn't be cutting you know he should
hire someone else he goes and practices
basketball or a lawyer who's a really
fast typer typist
should still hire a secretary to deal
with you know the paperwork so the
lawyer can focus on talking to the
client so there's all kinds of examples
where
just because you can do a task better
than someone else it still might make
sense for you to outsource that and hire
that person to do it to free your time
up to focus on where you're really good
compared to the other person
and so i guess the i guess the
alienation issue is dealt with to some
degree i read jung's psychological types
a long time ago and one of the
propositions he put forward was that
when slavery was eradicated in in the
west
we each became our own slaves that was
the price we paid for it and so we
slaved away for some portion of the day
but the consequence of that was that we
had some time where we could be free
citizens pursuing our leisure at will
and i think that's kind of an
interesting way of thinking about it too
is that the advantages of specialization
are such that it's worth
harnessing yourself to the
to the sled for a certain amount of time
per week
so that you can be relatively free in
everything else you do and the reason
that that's acceptable and beneficial is
because there isn't a better alternative
right and so yeah i think the way mises
would handle the alienation issue is
this is a few things he would say
kind of like what you were saying
earlier um about this idealic notion of
and by the way my wife and i want to get
some chickens too and so so i'm not
getting right
we want to do that too because we're
afraid of what's coming but mises points
out that
a graph of history in like per capita
living standards is like this like this
like this throughout the century and
then it goes like that starting in yeah
17 late 1700s the most important chart
in the world right and so and also
population explodes it's not merely that
it's the same population and just their
living center it's like
all of a sudden
you know the earth's population starts
growing very rapidly and so mises point
was
the only way that could happen is the
cities all of a sudden start growing you
know factories so
peasants left the farms and went to the
cities where the jobs were to speak
colloquially well yes and they left the
farms and went to the cities despite the
existence of the dark satanic mills
because all things considered it was
better in the dark satanic mills than it
was on the bloody farm right now to in
fairness
it wasn't just all
laissez faire and proper like there's
people on the left will argue that there
was what's called the enclosure movement
and that
like some of the land that the peasants
used to just live on and it was
considered there's
these you know rich people in cahoots
with the authorities came in and fenced
it off and kicked them on and so they
had no choice but to go to the cities
because they were dispossessed right but
that doesn't stop that doesn't
uh mitigate the fact that everywhere in
the world people are moving from rural
areas to the city right everywhere right
and faster and faster and faster and so
and so there's a general trend there
despite i mean it's very important to
separate out the general trends from the
aberrations right and you can point to
and like this is why i want to emphasize
this issue of power because we're
talking about first principles here and
and it's really important to get your
first principles about the nature of
your society correct and so you know one
theory is that value is produced by
labor and then the exploiters skim off
the excess labor
and and another theory is that no we
band together as free individuals we
sacrifice ourselves to become
specialists but the net consequence of
that is everyone's gain including our
own and we do that as free agents and
and that's not a fundamentally
exploitative system the fundamental
exploitation is our
subjugation to the demands of our
biological vulnerability not the tyranny
of the social institutions that actually
ameliorate that now and then we could
say well yes but there are aberrations
and sometimes
um
social institutions degenerate in the
direction of arbitrary power and
and and sometimes
they're not merely a consequence of
cooperative action but that's not the
main trend and that's not the central
tendency
right and and also to
just going along the lines of the
alienation so you're right there is a
trade-off i guess that
you can
once
that industrial revolution occurred and
people st and this is a point nieces
would stress too
that when you think about oh the factory
and that's just the fat cats no what are
they doing at the factory especially if
they're mass producing that's mass
production for the masses it was in the
middle ages where there were you know
boutique items made just for the rich
but the rise of modern capitalism where
people are going to factories and just
cranking stuff out and all this is so
monotonous that's because it's mass
production so that's showing that's what
the consumers are getting you're not
a factory doesn't have a bunch of
workers there sitting day in and day out
doing mindless tasks
just for a barren that there'd be too
much output it's for the masses so
there is that trade-off that you as the
consumer if you want all of this
cornucopia
of goods available that wouldn't have
been available in the year 1500 that's
because of this this new way of
upgrading so your price you pay for that
is that you have to serve to some degree
as a cog in the machine but you get to
decide which cog in which machine
ideally yes and so
um
and also too like we just take it for
granted that oh we have a weekend now we
only typically work five days a week and
even there
when people go into the office now they
don't really work eight hours they're on
twitter they're getting coffee you know
i'm saying so even now a work day
is not nearly as hard as it was 50 years
ago
and so
so yes you might feel like oh this job
i'm you know my boss doesn't appreciate
me and i
but
it's
it is that you know you have way more
free time now because productivity is
higher your wage rate now is way higher
than it would have been in the year 1850
and that's because of you know private
property rights mises would argue and
the incentives that entrepreneurs are
facing a market economy so and
ultimately yeah if you don't like your
job you can quit it and go do something
else if you okay so genuine market
economy all right right right so so
you're you're you're
a wage slave who can choose his slave
owner so to speak and that's
and maybe that is what constitutes
freedom when you also face biological
necessity that's the best you can do all
right so here's a proposition
property is theft
now that stems from the same kind of
ideas
the same marxist matrix let's say
and and the idea there is that
well people
gain
arbitrary control over
a natural resource and
fence it off from the use of others and
that should be a general resource
and
the mere fact that they have power
enables them to maintain the fences and
to
benefit preferentially from
whatever can be raised there perhaps
as a consequence of use of exploitation
of the labor of people who are then
allowed onto the
land and
again there's something that's sort of
folk attractive about that although i
think it also
dangerously incites
and justifies envy but
maybe we need
a better justification for private
property so
what do mises have to say about that
okay i don't know if mises made this
point but i've seen others like just
prima facie the statement property is
theft is almost a contradiction or a
paradox because
theft means somebody took your property
right so the notion of property per se
is built in there's no such thing
if property is a nonsensical concept
then so is theft right and so that's
that's really hard i would make that
point okay would make that point um
so i think what mises
one of the things he would say is
even the socialists who say oh rather
than you know the anarchy of production
or
how monstrous would it be to have all
the factories in the farmland in the
hands of
this narrow group of people
the capitalists let's call them or the
the bourgeoisie or whatever term we want
to use and then the mass of the
population is utterly dependent on their
decisions and look at look at how they
live their riotous living and their
drunkards and
you know these aren't reputable people
anyway or sober-minded people this is a
crazy system let's be more scientific
and rational and have experts running it
still they're just replacing
who the the narrow group of people are
who are in charge right it doesn't it
could not be that the people
collectively decide
which crops are going to get planted on
this acre of farmland because what if
people disagree there has to be some
mechanism by which we can agree okay
we're going to plant wheat here
and we're going to plant tobacco over
here or we're going to build a factory
here and this is what we're making that
people can have disagreements about that
and it's it's silly and naive to assume
oh if we just had reasonable people sit
down and think about what's right then
it would be obvious how to use all of
society's
you know means of production that no
it's not obvious at all and so
under a socialist approach where we get
rid of you know the evil or the theft of
private property at least in the means
of production
you're actually not getting rid of the
fact that a select few have to just
decide and everybody else has to go
along with it
and so to private property per se so
why
i mean
what it's easy to think of private
property actually as property but of
course the idea of private property is
really the idea that you can own
anything
and so then i guess if we go down to
first principles
what is it that you need to own in order
to make social institutions work well
i don't think there's anyone who
disputes the idea that you should own
the right to dispose of your labor as
you see fit
i mean even people who are on the
radical left i don't think would
allow for that degree of the dissolution
of ownership to take place
i mean their objection to begin with is
that people are basically enslaved by
exploitative
capitalist institutions and they should
be free to choose and that means seems
to me to mean that they own the right to
choose it's something like that
so what is it that you need to own
if we're banding together to maximize
productivity and we're doing it in a
cooperative way
rather than exploiting one another
fundamentally
aberrations be damned for the time being
what is it that we need to own what
rights do we need to own
right okay great so you're right that
it's it's interesting that when you talk
to
and obviously among you know there's
different groups like
socialist and marxist and leninist and
communist those are not all
interchangeable terms and the people who
believe in those things would get you
know take umbrage at people being sloppy
with you know so yeah well it's really
complicated in the case of places like
norway and sweden and well canada for
that matter because we're more socialist
than the us and i mean canada and norway
and sweden and finland and so on are
doing quite nicely all things considered
so these
compared to stella and the soviet union
for example so yeah these distinctions
make a tremendous amount of difference
so where i was going is to say though
that when i've talked to you know people
like antarctica communist let's say or
enter socialists that
and i ask them well
they will say that oh yeah people can
own their houses like as long as they're
modest or
workers should own their tools right so
that
they have no problem with a carpenter
owning a hammer and nails and a saw and
things like that so even though those
are means of production well it also but
then of course the problem comes up what
exactly do you mean by own
right
so if i own my house but i can't own a
factory but i can own my house well that
means i can't trade my house for a
factory
so i don't own my house in that regard
yeah so so there is there's something
there's something really fundamental
here that we need to sort out about
ownership so what does it mean to own
something well it
it means that you have the right to its
use
right yeah yeah you you your will
determines how it will be used right
and so to say that yeah i own a factory
means a modern yes not only do i get to
determine
what gets produced in it or if it just
sits there idle
but also um like you say
to really own it means i should be able
to sell it
to somebody else for right money for
anything or essentially for anything
well that's that's where things get
tricky right because
if ownership means something
it has to mean something like the right
to trade the thing you own for other
things you want because why the hell
else would you bother owning it
i mean it'll produce uh profit perhaps
but with that profit you still want to
be able to buy things that you can own
so it's the same problem so what we need
here at least to somebody the reason i'm
driving at all of this is because
we're facing a situation in our culture
where there are fundamental
revolutionary critiques at the first
principle level right right
we're not sovereign individuals we're
members of a group
we didn't band together for cooperation
we banded together
to maximize our own selfish me needs
our own selfish ambitions and we do that
as a consequence of the expression of
arbitrary power
that the fundamental relationship
between people in a hierarchy is
exploitative that that the enlightenment
idea of the sovereign individual is
nothing but a justification for
claims of power for the privileged group
i mean
these are fundamental critiques they go
all the way to the bottom which is why
i'm trying to chase things down to the
bottom i'm also and i want to go to this
too at some point
it's an attractive set of ideas it's an
optimistic set of ideas but it isn't
instilling the same revolutionary fervor
among a minority of of young people
let's say in our culture that these
that these more radical uh
the more radical critical ideas are and
so we also have to address that problem
is that this is kind of a nice way of
looking at the world it's it's
optimistic it's it's positive but it's
not romantically attractive and it's
being attacked madly
and so we can't defend it very well so
okay so so we'll we'll sketch that out
back to ownership
so so yeah
i i think
it at some point in this
you know discussion you know what mises
would stress is to say hey let's not
lose sight of the fact that
and just so you know um dr peterson he
mises was not a natural law theorist
right so even though plenty of people
like libertarians
um
love the work of mises and
people who are very ideological and and
have views as to like where property
comes from and ethically mises was
was was more utilitarian or pragmatic
and i think he would just say
you know yeah i'm happy to have these
discussions about the philosophy and the
underpinnings of justice and so forth
but
push comes to shove
the means of pro like factories and
farmland and uh crude oil deposits and
mineral other minerals and things like
that those all need to be owned
privately too because you need to have
market prices for those things because
a given business enterprise needs to be
able at the end of
the accounting period to say
were we profitable or not and that's the
only way we can know if it's using
scarce resources effectively okay so one
reason for ownership is that it's very
difficult to monetize something
without that ownership and if you can't
monetize it you can't calculate its
value and if you can't calculate its
value
you can't use it or you you can't know
whether you're using it efficiently or
not well but that would be the same
thing essentially because if you don't
use it efficiently you're going to have
to stop using it pretty damn quickly
and so
to some degree pricing is the antidote
to the tragedy of the commons that's
another way of looking at it is that so
for example in the in the oceans no one
owns the oceans
at least not past once you get out 200
miles it's free for all essentially and
so the consequence of that is that
everyone is incentivized to take every
goddamn fish as fast as they possibly
can and that's exactly what's happened
and it's because the fish are free
right but they're not because they're a
finite resource and so the problem is we
haven't monitor or a problem a potential
problem is that we haven't assigned
a monetized value to the fish
and so once they're pulled into an
economy they're worth something but out
there free floating it's every man for
himself and so that means that
without private property you know you
could make a case that private property
leads to the despoiling of the natural
environment say okay well what about
those situations where there is no
private property well then you get
instantaneous despoiling of the natural
environment because there's no incentive
to maintain it
so we could say you need to own things
so that
your
commitment to your specialization
is paid for
right so i want you to become a brain
surgeon that means i have to give you
something
and to give you something means you get
to own it to to dispose of it as you see
fit
and so we're gonna we want to
incentivize everyone to specialize so
that we can exploit each other with
maximal efficient efficiency
and that's to everyone's good it's
something to to that's in everyone's
best interests it's something like that
and so we need private property to
manage the incentive
and and then you also said to price
things properly because that's also an
important consideration right so
historically
um even before mises came along yeah the
the critics of socialism warned
about the incentive issue and like to
say hey there are some really productive
people if they're just getting paid you
know from each according to his ability
to each according to his needs why would
a super productive person you know exert
himself so much if he's just going to
get
food based on how many people are in his
household or something you know that
kind of thing
um so that was a standard thing but then
the socialist
countered that and said well no in a
socialist society there'd be a new
socialist man who would just you know
give
out of altruism you know just to benefit
to be the benefactor of his fellow man
and it's only when you grow up in a
capitalist system that you're
greedy and self-centered because you
have to be to survive
so mises came along and he in his
argument you know he acknowledged the
truth of the incentive issues but his
was more of a of a calculation or or
just a
knowing what to do
and saying you know even if we stipulate
for the sake of argument that all the
comrades are willing to do whatever the
central planner's telling the central
planners
truly want the best for their subjects
it's just you don't know where should we
locate the factories how much how many
cars should we make should we build more
food distribution centers should we have
more farms here or there how many of our
incoming you know of our crop of young
scholars should go into these different
technical fields okay and the reason the
reason that you don't know that is
because in order to know that
in order to know the price of one thing
you have to know the price of everything
else right right that's the fundamental
problem so
and
then the problem is worse because well
how in the world can you calculate the
fundamental price of everything because
that's an insuperable computational
obstacle
and the answer is well you distribute
the computational problem to the maximum
number of actors and you try to bring
everything under the monetization web
right and you and there are places where
that where we have real trouble with
that where we can't monetize something
accurately um
yeah so there's there's
areas where it doesn't work very well
but in general yes if you just think
about what does it mean in a
decentralized market economy with
private property not just for carpenters
owning hammers but for the whole factory
being owned by a small group of people
or one person you know everything is
owned privately
and then yeah people have accountants
and at the end like i say of an
accounting period they look back and say
how did we do and if they're profitable
just think through what does that mean
it means
the their customers gave them more
dollars than they had to spend on the
resources to make that stuff the goods
of the services well we could use an
analogy imagine you're a carpenter
and you want to build a house
but you don't have a ruler
you don't have any way to measure length
right well
so maybe you eyeball it maybe you get
pretty good at that but for maybe you
can't even do that so you can't measure
length and now you have to build a house
well you can't because you have to
measure and so then the fundamental
principle here is that
money
is the measure of value and it's
computed as a consequence of a
distributed network
and that's the only reason it works and
each person is pursuing something of
value insofar as they're capable of
doing that and they make
some pricing decisions
on the basis of their specialized
expertise and then we sum the
consequences of that specialized
computation and we have a price for
everything or virtually everything and
because we have a price for everything
we can roughly decide what to do
so it's best to think of this really as
a computational enterprise
i believe right yeah yeah mises used the
term calculation yeah and that was so
you're exactly right he argued that
one of the most important distinctions
of modern civilization was the ability
to apply arithmetic to human action
right right right so so yeah this is the
measurement issue and so
we're we're basically making the case
that
you you can't
you can't get anywhere unless you can
measure
and money is the measure and it's a
measure and so the proposition that
central planning will work is the
proposition that you can
substitute one expert mind for a million
distributed expert minds
and that's just not the case it's
obviously not the case because each
person is going to have
knowledge that's pertains to their
locality that isn't accessible and
that's another element of specialization
that isn't accessible to everyone
and so it's much better to let everyone
make the decisions and sum them and and
so we have this this free market society
isn't a mechanism
to allow property holders to exploit
others let's say it's a mechanism
that the entire human race uses to
calculate the comparative value of
everything
right and that makes thought possible
and miese does point that out when he
talks about arithmetic is that it
enables us to do arithmetic
and we can decide is it worth it
yeah and so
hayek um
who was you know a follower of mises and
won the nobel prize in 74 for a lot of
stuff he had a
discussion where he was saying
for example if a if a tin mine collapses
in africa or something
everybody around the world who uses tin
needs to use less of it at least in the
near term until they get that mine up
and running again and so in a market
economy the way that happens is the
price of tin goes up
and so you're saying like some factory
owners a signal in north dakota doesn't
even need to know why
it's irrelevant he doesn't need to know
the particulars of the mind he just
needs to know 10 is more scarce now than
it was yesterday so to if you can
use something else on the margin
and that's exactly what happens when the
price goes up people who can substitute
out of 10 for something else do so but
for firms that absolutely need 10
there's no other way to do it right and
they don't need to know anything about
tin that's what's so cool about money is
that you don't need to know anything
about what it is that you're purchasing
and thank god for that because
we don't know anything about anything
you know so if you go i mean
i've tried to buy printers
which is very very difficult because
there's like 300 printers you know it's
like how the hell do you possibly know
which printer is the right printer
and the answer basically is
well
roughly speaking you can use price you
can assume the printer is worth whatever
it's
whatever the price is it's it's as good
an indication of the quality as you're
going to manage
and
and thank god for that because otherwise
you wouldn't be able to make a decision
i mean i ran into this sort of problem
trying to price some things that i
produced i produced these software
programs myself and my collaborators um
one of them the self-authoring suite is
designed to help people write about
their past and their present and to make
a plan for the future we were trying to
price that and it was unbelievably
difficult decision
and it started me thinking about pricing
you know if you make it really expensive
well that's some indication that it's of
high value but it limits the number of
people who can use it if you make it we
thought well maybe we should make it
free
would more people use it because we were
basic we wanted people to use it you
know i mean
we had other motives i suppose but
fundamentally the motive was well
we have some psychological knowledge
let's see if we can share this with
people as broadly as possible but our
conclusion eventually was that free was
the wrong price
we couldn't generate enough profit to
continually improve it
we couldn't justify the effort that we
put into it and so we're likely to start
looking at other things because we
weren't incentivized properly and people
might respond that something worth zero
isn't worth anything
right
and that was just one pricing decision
and so you know we set it at a moderate
to low price and that seems to have
worked but it really did introduce me to
the complexities of pricing
and people were willing to pay what we
charge for it and so maybe we should
have charged more who the hell knows or
perhaps less but
okay so so let's go back to first
principles a little bit so
people need to own things because if
they don't
they don't we can't incentivize them to
specialize in production and then we
don't have anything
and so ownership allows for
incentivization essentially so
that's one component but i'm saying an
independent
issue is even if
right now we've let's assume we have all
the stuff that's you know the resources
are available and people have studied to
be brain surgeons and carpenters and
whatever
even so we don't know
what to do with all these resources
without having right right okay i got to
get that in my head because that's okay
is there another is there some is there
another attribute we got two there
ownership allows for proper
incentivization and it also allows for
pricing and that's necessary to provide
comparative information about
comparative value absolutely crucial is
there anything else that ownership is
key to there probably is but is there
anything else we're missing well i mean
not in terms of like the narrow
economics of it but i think the broader
so mises would call himself a classical
liberal or he would just say liberal but
for our terms we mean classical liberal
like you know individual rights and so
on and i think he would just say in that
paradigm
private property was the ultimate
bulwark against
oppression by the political authorities
that okay okay so that's a good one too
so you might say well
we need
maybe it's better to have a thousand
rich people than one tyrant
because you've distributed the tyranny
at least right now there's tension
between the tyrants and maybe it's even
better if there's a hundred thousand
tyrants
because they're competing amongst
themselves and i mean i think you could
make that case because one of the
factors that delimited the power of the
absolute monarch say as england
developed was the fact that there were
nobles who also had independent basis of
power so ownership also gives
individuals
authority and power
right another way of
looking that's part of incentivization
but it's also stabilizes societies right
so it's
so if you think about it um
it's true you know the marxists do have
a grain of truth that the average worker
especially with no savings is sort of at
the mercy of all the big firm you know
oh gee i need a job and right now
there's really just a hundred companies
that are viable
that might hire me and
and if you know if i don't get along
with them or if i don't kowtow and do
what they want be a yes man then you
know i'm out and i have to just do
whatever
but how in the world are you is that
situation improved i think let's get rid
of the hundred owners and just have the
state be the sole employer and tell
everyone here's where you're gonna work
that there you've replaced like you say
the hundred
petty tyrants where ultimately you can
just quit and go somewhere else
now you have to leave the country if you
don't get along with your boss who's the
state well and you can see too yeah well
and then and imagine also the
disproportion in power okay so let's go
to that there's a centralized authority
that's making all the decisions and then
there's all these citizens and they're
all equal
well yeah but they're not equal in
relationship to the centralized
authority they're radically unequal they
have no power whatsoever and so now if
you look at a place like communist china
at least the central tyrannical
tendency of the state is counterbalanced
by the authority and power of the
tycoons
and you've got to think about that as
something that's better at least there's
a competition between tyranny and at
that point
even if you're very very cynical about
the whole situation it it's a good thing
that there are
locales of power that are independent of
the state of the state's central
authority
right and that's merely because the
state even if it was benevolent might be
wrong
so just in terms of diversity of opinion
we'd want to have multiple power sources
now you know i've also talked to my
brother-in-law helped me sort of puzzle
this through too you know
there's some utility in having some
people who specialize in the ownership
of money and so they have a tremendous
amount of money partly because some
things are really expensive to do
so if you want to build a factory to
build
microchips for example that's a couple
of billion dollars in investment minimum
and so unless we have these huge pools
of freely available capital
then that requires a certain amount of
dis
proportion in distribution right so that
there are some people who are extremely
rich we couldn't do any of the things
that riches require if we didn't have
people who were rich
and so so let tell me what you think
about this so
is it the case that
distribution of economic resources to
the poorest is dependent on their
availability to the rich first
so you think about cell phones when they
first come out they're like twenty five
thousand dollars
and so there's some people who can
afford a twenty five thousand dollar
cell phone and they buy them and then
now they're worth twenty thousand
dollars and then
more people can buy them because it's
the twenty thousand dollar price range i
mean if we didn't have radical
inequalities in income distribution
would we ever be able to introduce
new expensive products into the market
um
well let me answer this way and if if
you want to press me i can try to
elaborate more but
i think for sure what mises would say
and i would agree with this is
for the introduction of new products you
do want to have private property and the
ability of certain
people to have accumulated vast fortunes
because if you think about how did some
person get to be a billionaire
it was only because of that person's
superior foresight
in anticipating what the consumers
wanted and that's how you got to that
position and then that person then to
decide
there's this new technology called a
cell phone or a cellular phone
yeah i think it's worth sinking millions
of dollars and it's seen if this will
pan out
it's the you know who's making that
decision it's the person who's got the
proven track record
so far whereas if you had a different
system where oh no we don't allow
individuals to accumulate vast fortunes
the state owns everything
then it's going to be a committee that's
always going to guess and say okay bring
in the new proposals let's vote on it
you know like so it's there's not as
much skin in the game to use you know
that popular phrase now that it's not
that individuals own money
and so that's
like
you could just see how given human
nature and the limits of what people's
expertise is that
d distributing and decentralizing it and
allowing for the possibility of massive
fortunes to accumulate
is a better engine for innovation that
now people can specialize a certain
billionaire who doesn't know anything
about phones like he made his money
with cars might say i'm going to pass
and then i don't know anything about
that whereas somebody else who's more
technically savvy might invest in it but
there needs to be some way you can't
just invest in every
promoter who says hey i've got this new
product that's going to revolutionize
the world
because most of them right so your
argument basically is well there are
people out there who specialized and
developed expertise within a certain
domain and as a consequence they've
accumulated a fortune and that marks
accepting aberrations that marks the
development of that expertise it's a
pragmatic marker for the development of
that expertise you want those people
making decisions in their area
and if they make decisions in another
area and it's a bad decision they're
just going to lose their money right and
so it's self
correcting and like you said maybe this
is what you're if you said
brother-in-law was getting it but there
are people in a in a market economy who
specialize in
investments like they're good at just
picking companies like like warren
buffett or whatever you know use a
popular example so it's not that warren
buffett necessarily is good at running a
car factory but he knows
what team is going to be good at doing
that like he can just interview people
and get a sense of i think this is this
firm's going to do well over the next 10
years and so you know there is that so
someone who's just good at investing and
picking winners in the stock market if
you really are good at that over time
you accumulate money and then you have
more decision as to which firms get
funded so again it's like a meritocracy
and all this stuff presupposes there's
property rights and you know people
aren't stealing it from yes and free
action and liability assuming you know
the rules
then yeah over time who is it that's
made a boatload of money in the stock
market the people who have successfully
predicted better than everybody else
which stocks are likely to go up or they
sold the ones that were before they went
down and that's exactly the kind of
person you want
deploying the scarce amount of capital
funds
you know sort of guiding the trajectory
of our industrial base well that's the
person you would turn to if you were
looking for advice so it seems like
that's the sort of person that you'd
want now that means that the thing about
that again and this is a moral issue is
that means
those of us who don't have billions of
dollars have to put up with the fact
that there are people who do
right and and
i suppose it's it's tempting to assume
that they've
gathered their um
fortune as a consequence of you know
some misbegotten adventure that involves
oppression and
and unfair extraction and of course
there's always some truth in that
because all systems are susceptible to
corruption to some degree see i've been
thinking about this idea of systemic
racism a lot lately and
it's very very treacherous term
and and purposefully so i believe
or or maybe it's evolved that way in
some sense because terms that are
particularly treacherous are difficult
to dispense with
it isn't the racism part of that that's
the problem although it's that it's sort
of it's the heavyweight
of the of the two
you say racism and everyone responds
well that's a terrible thing and then to
object to anything that has racism
appended to it is a very treacherous
enterprise because it looks like you're
objecting to something that's obviously
terrible i mean even if you're a filthy
greedy capitalist you want to exploit
everybody from each race to the maximum
degree possible and so even for you
racism is going to be a terrible thing
but then there's this systemic issue you
see and that's what and that sort of
snuck in there systemic
well
systemic
implies central
tendency right because otherwise you
wouldn't use the word systemic and so
the proposition is essentially that the
central tendency of the social
institutions and institutions is racism
rather than an aberration in their
behavior or a deviation from the central
tendency and what we're trying to sort
out right here is what the central
tendency is
and so we're saying well people band
together for productive purposes they
specialize because that is advantageous
with regards to maximizing productivity
and distribution because of the pricing
issue
it's not a matter of exploitation you
have to specialize to do this and
there's a price to be paid for that but
the but the price to be paid
is offset by the price that you are paid
for specializing
and so that's a completely different
view of and so a system like that isn't
going to be systemically prejudice
because it works at counter purposes to
its central tendency if productivity is
the aim and the goal then you want to
exploit everyone equally
right so just on the narrow point that
you made
i just want to amplify it that yes in a
market economy there is an inbuilt
penalty for irrational prejudice so you
know you've got okay so now we can
define irrational prejudice too and this
gets to the issue of merit right so
imagine you're making widgets
well then the hiring criteria is going
to be facility in making widgets
and anything that isn't relevant to
facility
in making widgets is prejudicial
and if you allow those prejudices to
influence your hiring decisions you're
going to be less competitive than
someone who doesn't
and so the central tendency is against
prejudice not for it it has to be if
if you define prejudice as
deviation from the proclivity to select
for the desired output
right and so for example um you know
this the male female alleged wage gap
and i'm you know i know
i saw your wonderful interview um on
that issue
but
on its own terms just think it's odd
then if it really were true that in the
united states
you know
men and women you know men or women only
get paid whatever the number is 88 cents
for a man for the same work it's a
mystery then we'll so how come all the
firms that are run by greedy capitalists
aren't hiring just women because they're
right because they make a 20 they make a
profit instantly by doing so right
and so if they're greedy and exploitive
why aren't they jumping all over that
the counter argument has to be well
they're so prejudiced against women that
they'll allow that prejudice to override
their greed
right and what's interesting too is it's
not merely that
like so i don't have to insist that
every single employer thinks like that
just all it would take is
five to ten percent like for example why
don't the female owned businesses at
least just hire all women to take
advantage of the fact that women
will do the same work you know what i
mean so it's the other the side that has
to maintain that no it's this blind
irrational you know sexism that
overrides the greed
has to well they have to explain well
why
what the hell's the motivation exactly
is that so what is this that there's
a widely distributed cabel of owners
who are so prejudiced against women in
the main that merely to sustain their
prejudice against women they're willing
to take a 12 profit hit year after year
and none of them are deviating from that
to gain a competitive advantage right
and then that's the theory right and
why can't women who see this it's so
obvious then why don't they start
opening businesses
to at least you know help pay their
female
uh you know sisters 95 cents to them you
know it's so it's yeah it's 89 for that
matter right so it's weird that that
system so and then of course they would
then respond and say well it's because
of the you know and they pushed the
sexism back like you say into the the
system and i think you're right it's an
insidious term because they use racism
or sexism is the the bad thing to taint
it but then it's unbelievably insidious
and that that's partly why i wanted to
have this discussion it's like
is it systemic that's the issue not is
it racist yeah yeah there's racism no
kidding there's all sorts of arbitrary
stupidity
no one debates that but systemic means
central tendency and so what we're
trying to clear up here today at least
in part is what are the what is the
central tendencies of our psychological
motivation as individuals and the
central tendency with regards to how we
organize our societies
and we need to make a counter argument
to the proposition that it's blind it's
the blind application of power which i
think is not only a weak argument i
think it's it's it flies in the face of
the truth it's a it's an anti-truth
because people don't organize their
social institutions on the basis of
exploitative power it's not even very
efficient to do that right it's because
people aren't incentivized when they're
tyrannized and so yes so that's another
area where i think
what you know i've heard your lectures
coincides very nicely with mises work
when you say
yes there are hierarchies but they're
not based merely on
pure power you know there's there's some
merit involved or sometimes there's and
that's what mises says that
he like he would talk about you know
they'd refer to like the cotton king or
the the barons of industry
and he said in a market economy
the the people who were at the top the
john d like why is john d rockefeller
you know why was he on top because he
delivered kerosene at much lower prices
than his competitors did that and the
same thing can be said for walmart right
and for bill gates for that matter who
made
who made i remember what happened when
microsoft started to develop gates
bundled software together and sold it
for like one-tenth the price of his
competitors it was and he just wiped
them out
and so and it happened very very rapidly
and so okay so here's another
issue with ownership i robert breedlove
brought this up today on twitter it's
not his idea but other people have made
the same case but he did it quite nicely
he said that
private property should the right to
private property should also be
considered the responsibility of private
property and responsibility properly had
it's like
okay now you here's a car and you own it
so what are you going to do with that
car
well
are you going to take care of it are you
going to wreck it
well what if a thousand of you own it so
do you take better care of a rental car
your own car
and so then the question is well if you
own something do you take better care of
it than if you don't own it
and i think everybody can kind of answer
that question for themselves
it's it's
it's in your best interest to take care
of something that you own
and maybe you don't do a very good job
of it but all that implies is that you
do even a worse job if you didn't own it
right and just to extend that against
the macesian framework
that's what he would say is again the
critical function of
having prices
and just simple accounting like mises
quoted gerta who said um one of the
modern miracles or the best inventions
of the human mind was double entry
bookkeeping or something like i i forget
the exact word yeah
that seems like an odd thing for you
know affiliates well it's worth it it's
worth yes it is an odd thing it's first
of all you should define double entry
bookkeeping so everyone knows what that
is
okay so that you know on your
for in terms of accounting that there's
like the liabilities and then on the
opposite side of the balance you know
you have the or sorry you have the the
assets and then the liabilities and the
and the um the capital and the company
so that every transaction you sort of
see the mirror image and you can just
keep track of what's happening
and mises point was that sort of trivial
thing that the socialists just say oh
that's just an appendage of the market
economy to put some numbers on it and
what but he's like no that's critical
because the
it allows the owner to know
are we have we squandered our funds like
our capital at the end of the period is
it higher or lower and it's sort of like
a scorecard and so i'm just that what
you just said reminding me that's like
to say
without prices it's not merely that you
wouldn't have the incentive you wouldn't
even know
did i add to the stockpile of what i've
been entrusted with to be a steward for
you know in society of the like these
portions of resources it's my
i own
and did that go up or down without
market prices you literally don't even
know whether it went up or down so it it
would be like if you had a car and not
just knowing do you take care or not but
not even be able to see it or not even
to be able to open the hood and tell if
there was an engine inside like you
wouldn't know am i driving it too hard
if you couldn't check up on it in some
way so that's what market prices do
if you've earned a profit that's a
signal or feedback from the entire
society that in a sense the consumers
say you've done a good job using scarce
resources
that you've transferred resources into
something okay so
okay so ownership buys us
um incentive
it buys us stewardship
it buys us
measurement and those aren't replaceable
especially measurement that might be the
most crucial of all of them because the
others fall without measurement
you can't even keep track of what you're
doing that's the point you're just
making now
yeah so we can have yeah me jesus has a
phrase where he said the central
planners without market prices would be
groping in the dark well that's that's
the it that's that's a huge issue i read
in solzhenits and i believe that the
central planners
under in the stellen soviet union had to
make something like 50 000 pricing
decisions a day
and well you can't even make 50 000
decisions a day i'm right that's
impossible but
and i don't know how they managed it but
without
right there's always an assumption
there's always an implicit assumption on
the basis of people who are pushing
central planning that the data will
somehow be there
for the planners to take right okay so
there's there's a couple more things i
want to cover here and
so
the business cycle
let's talk about that because that's if
we talked about general economics and
the philosophy of economics and one of
the things we tried to
understand was how
we should regard the organization of
social institutions and the motivation
of individuals the motivation of
individuals isn't to exploit other
people it's to stave off catastrophe
using social cooperation as the means to
do so it's something like that and the
willingness to accept the sacrifice of
specialization to participate in that
process
with the benefit of ownership and all
the things that we discussed that emerge
as a consequence of that
and that isn't something that anyone
decided that's the other thing we should
point out is these systems have evolved
across time
i mean rad there's been rational inputs
in all of that
and and rational formalizations of the
system but this is an evolved system and
it's a consequence of distributed
computation running across hundreds and
thousands of years
right and i should mention that like
within the austrian school there's
different emphasis so mises was was very
rationalistic
so he would say oh the reason people
engage in social cooperation
is because they use their reason and
they understand the higher productivity
of the division of labor whereas hayek
who's also a big figure in the austrian
school
he was more
evolutionary in the sense of different
cultures for whatever reason you know
like these people
just didn't like cannibalism for some
reason and then they would tend to
multiply more than
cultures that thought cannibalism was
okay you know to me so for him it wasn't
so much that they had to understand why
it was just those that happen to think
oh no you know private property is a
good thing or you should be able to or
if some society
thought merchants were a noble
profession that they would explode and
take off and then they would conquer
everyone else who thought that no
working for the government was the only
thing that mother should hold right
right well so there might be an
evolutionary process at work here so to
speak
as far as that works in the social world
random
innovation followed by selection there's
certainly some of that but it's also
necessary for us to understand
rationally what the consequence of that
right is
at least so we don't disturb it
unduly when we're tempted to right and
that's something that hayek brought up a
lot i think in his noble acceptance
speech too is to say
the problem with the socialist or more
generally like people coming along
looking at social institutions that
we've inherited over thousands of years
saying that doesn't make sense to me i
think we can do better and just to throw
that out and that led to all the
of the 20th century like the smartest
guys in the room
not understanding the social utility of
some of these traditions and so you know
hayek would argue that's actually not
being scientific and rational like let's
think through there must be some reason
yeah well the big the big issue there
for me is you know as look for anyone
anyone who's intelligent it's a very
complicated because we do
use planning in our day-to-day lives you
know and i mean that's an assumption of
the austrian school and so then you
might say well
isn't there a role for planning at the
highest levels of social organization
and the answer to that has to be
something like the more complex the
problem the less likely that
individual rationality is going to be
able to solve it you have to start
moving towards distributed computational
systems to solve incredibly complex
problems
yeah exactly right and that
they talk about that a lot in the
austrian tradition too to say
we shouldn't even concede to the
socialists this term planner because in
the market economy like you said dr
piezo there's lots of planning like the
ceos and the you know the vps of finance
and marketing they sit down and they're
planning all the time like should we
introduce this new product line should
we build a factory here but it's
decentralized whereas what the
socialists mean by planning is no a
select group of people with political
power
are going to do the planning and so
everybody right
it's like systemic racism
centralized planning the planning sounds
good it's the centralized that's the
problem the more centralized the
planning the more room for catastrophic
error
right right
yeah okay so the
political oppression too like we said
that it's
it's not a narrowly economic issue but
but yes since looking at history we know
it is possible that sometimes people do
really awful things
that's another independent reason you
would want to limit how much power a few
people have and to give them the power
over the whole economy that's a very
risky thing to do it's not merely that
they might not make enough eggs they
might send people to work in death camps
okay so are there more criticisms of
socialism lurking inside the austrian
school at the level of first principles
or have we discussed most of them
i i think
hitting the calculation issue is the
critical contribution that mises made i
mean he
right he goes through all like
inconsistencies in the marxist worldview
and like the polylogism and some mises
says
they say there's polylogism but they've
never taken you know a theorem from
economics and shown
oh this is true according to bourgeois
logic but proletarian logic has a
different axiom and therefore it's step
four the proof is wrong he just says
they just say that you know what i mean
so he's mises does really get into rolls
up his sleeves and critiques marxism but
in terms of for your audience i think
that the main thing was
why calculation is such a
flaw for socialism but the market
economy sells it with private property
and money prices
okay okay let's talk about the business
cycle now okay if you don't mind so i'm
gonna give you free reign to do that
i'll interrupt of course
okay sure so
in this like again like i said in the
beginning is i think
one of the
key contributions of the austrian school
that even other free-market oriented
economists like the chicago school don't
have
so in the austrian tradition like we
said prices are serve a very important
social function it's like you say
there's like decentralized people all
around the world with local information
and the price system is the nexus by
which that gets communicated around like
hayek even likened it to a nervous
system
and so
that's a sense in which the whole system
stays rational if you want to use that
phrase or how do we
husband our resources economically you
need market prices to have that so okay
but now and specifically what is it that
interest rates do and in the austrian
school they say that has to do with
inter-temporal planning like
long-term decisions that's where
interest rates really play a decisive
role and so give a silly example
you know you're an entrepreneur trying
to decide whether to build an apartment
building you know so you can know how
much the steel costs the concrete the
lumber the glass you know how much it'll
cost to build you can even forecast you
know oh in this neighborhood i'll be
able to rent it for such and such and
i'll bring in this revenue
so over the next 20 years every year
i'll bring in this much net income
here's the upfront cost
should i build it or not a critical
input to that decision that calculation
is what's the interest rate because the
interest rate is really high then you
won't build it if it's really low then
you might okay so let me harass you
about the interest rate sure so
why do we have an interest rate
what is it exactly
okay so
the the austrian framework loosely
speaking
it has to do with um let me say like the
the amount of impatience the the amount
by which
people are willing to defer consumption
as long as they get more down the road
so the higher the interest rate it's
like the bigger the penalty is on
waiting
so a lo so if society is very future
oriented and
very
long-term thinking they're willing to
save a lot
other things equal that tends to push
down interest rates so firms can borrow
at cheap rates and invest in long-term
projects so people are willing to do so
why do you think our interest rates are
so low right now okay so right now i
think it's because of
the intervention of central banks and so
this ties into you know the austrian
concern with that is
yeah
the low interest rates are giving the
signal to entrepreneurs go ahead and
invest in really long-term projects but
it's the wrong right because okay so
your money
in conditions of low interest
you have money
says in a bank account
so it can be translated into spendable
currency instantaneously and it's
hypo it's performing a function that's
reflected in the interest rate
and so if it's just sitting there
collecting 0.1 percent and the inflation
rate is three percent your money is
losing value across time so you're going
to be incentivized to go find something
more useful to do with the money
hypothetically
right so it's a two-pronged thing that
low interest rates other things equal
make people not save as much
right because why would i save if i'm
only earning like say 0.1 whereas if you
were earning 10 in your savings account
you might save more but then on the flip
side too businesses who want to borrow
funds to go start a project right can
get it and a much better channel the
idea of saving is complicated too
because you know
the typical
folk notion of a billionaire is
something like scrooge mcduck you
remember scrooge mcduck he had this
money bin full of money and of course as
long as all the money is in scrooge
mcduck's
money bin
no one else has access to it it's like
he's he's stuffed a
500 foot mattress full of
cash and he's just sitting on it
occupying it hoarding it but when we
save money in a modern economy that
isn't what happens at all we put money
unless we put it in the proverbial
mattress we put it in the bank
and that enables other people to use it
and they can use a substantial fraction
of it to go and pursue pursuits that in
principle have to be more productive
than the interest rate that we're being
awarded
so we're not hoarding the money
right so what everything you just said
is true but what's
ironic is if you think about it even if
people did do that
it would actually be socially
advantageous right so
someone goes out and produces a bunch of
goods and services and people give them
cash
and then he goes and just stores it in
his basement if you think about that
that person's going around doing work
for people and giving them benefits
and then he doesn't get with you without
consuming anything right right exactly
except future consideration
and so if he never like in terms of like
what's the worst case scenario he never
spends it that's actually no that would
so if he never spends it it's deflation
right so it drives down the cost of
goods right right so it's just ironic
that but you're right right and the
other thing too
for most of today's billionaires it's
not even that they have money in a
checking account that the bank had lent
is that they own stock
in companies they created
so it's like bill gates or whatever
right so what they have is
it's very interesting because
in some sense they have power
and in some sense they have authority
and in some sense they can exercise
compulsion but they also have a
tremendous amount of responsibility
because you really have to ask and i've
asked myself this many times especially
in recent years
do you want that responsibility
like having a billion dollars is no joke
i mean yes you i think ted turner
famously calculated that if you spent as
much as you could every possible day
just on on
what are those goods that disappear
consumable goods you know
you use them and then they're gone
you could spend 400 million dollars in
your lifetime and and that would be flat
out nothing but hedonistic spending so
maybe you have 20 billion dollars and
well that's like you're basically
running
a pretty good-sized country at that
point right and it's not as i i read a
biography of howard hughes you know
howard hughes had obsessive-compulsive
disorder and he got very ill in his
later years and
like his money just evaporated around
him as soon as he was unable to stay on
top of it it just disappeared like mad
and that makes perfect sense because
money
is obviously valuable and if you don't
keep an eye on it it has a tendency to
distribute itself elsewhere
extraordinarily rapidly
and so this envy of people who are
extraordinarily well off you know it's
it's based on a misapprehension about
the nature of their existence at least
to some i'm not making a case for the
wonderfulness of abject poverty believe
me i
i mean
i'm not doing that at all it's just that
the picture isn't so simple you do have
a tremendous amount of responsibility
along with all that money and if you
don't exercise the responsibility
properly all that happens is the money
disappears extremely rapidly
right which is again another reason just
in terms of pragmatic considerations
that you're mentioning
a while ago about would you redistribute
you know is there some utility or like
allowing for the existence of
billionaire speculators or you know
stock investors and things
and i would say yes that
it's not it's not correct to think that
oh the reason they achieved that is
because they siphoned it off from
everybody else that no largely well
let's okay let's go after that okay they
inherited it
let's start with that so justify that
okay well there i would say
the person who you know if i go out and
create a fortune
most people are okay with me being able
to go and spend it at the casino or you
know smoke it away or buy yachts or
whatever
but i'm not allowed to give it to my kid
that seems weird
so it's yeah well i guess the the
rejoinder would be well why should your
child have a special advantage but my
objection to that objection is
okay
aren't you trying to give your children
all the special advantages that you can
and isn't that what you're supposed to
do now special doesn't necessarily mean
at the expense of someone else see this
is the critical issue here is that
what we're facing in our culture war is
the proposition that those who have have
as a consequence of exploitation
and that there's no such thing as merit
there's just different there's there's
exploitations justification for itself
now we already narrowly defined merit
right so when we say our society is
meritocratic
what we would say is no more than this
and maybe merit is the wrong word and
that's a big problem
if i'm
hiring a dishwasher merit for me is that
person's ability to wash dishes and
nothing else so the merit is very and so
we need a better word than merit it's
like functional utility or something
like that because a company even by law
you have to do this you know if you're
going to hire someone in the united
states the labor laws are very clear
about this point you have to do a job
analysis which breaks down the job into
its functional units let's say and then
you have to look through your candidate
pool and you have to find the person
who's most qualified to perform those
tasks using the best measurement
techniques that are currently available
if you don't do that you're in violation
of the law and so that's another
rejoinder to the notion of systemic
racism and those bloody laws have teeth
they're not trivial
so and they're heavily enforced but
merit isn't defined in terms of ethical
utility precisely it's defined very
narrowly in terms of pragmatic function
that you're meritorious to the degree
your meritorious in this particular
situation to the degree that you can
perform that particular function
and you can't say that a society is
greedy and exploitative
and say at the same time that it isn't
predicated on merit
using that narrow definition of merit
because you're not going to be very
effective at being greedy and exploitive
if you're not selecting for
productive capacity let's say and i
i think just more generally on these
points that you're raising
like i don't think most people would
would say
yeah it's a tragedy some
kids are born without legs like that
happens
it would be
crazy for us to chop everyone's legs off
to say well this is the only way to make
it fair right that you would realize no
that doesn't help anybody including the
people who naturally would have been
born without legs like they benefit from
being in a society so likewise
i understand hey it's not fair if some
guy's rich
and gives his fortune to his kid
when you know i didn't get that but by
all's you know
i'm fortunate that my parents stayed
married and that you know they valued
well yeah that that's right that's
exactly the issue right is that
this
we
and i saw this
watch this happen so to speak on
from a historical perspective looking at
what happened in places like the soviet
union and in communist china still
happening in places like north korea
where
every single person has enough of a
comparative advantage
so that there's some dimension along
which they can be rightfully regarded as
an oppressor
because they have
we all differ in our advantages and
disadvantages all i have to do is point
to your comparative advantages despite
your disadvantages and say well you're a
member of the oppressed oppressor class
because well you're physically healthy
you're
you know you're you're not you're near
six feet tall instead of four foot eight
you're
you know you have use of all your limbs
you had parents who stayed married
you're of above average intelligence etc
etc i can make that lit so what we would
say instead is that for maximum fairness
you allow people their comparative
advantages but you encourage them to
specialize in trade
right right and that
you're not
again you're not you're actually not
helping the
the disadvantaged on whatever that
narrow criterion is that you're looking
at that moment of analysis
by him stringing everybody else
on that one dimension so you're exactly
right that yeah rather than looking
around it
it light rather than looking with envy
at other people or saying that's unfair
to say oh no this person has this
ability that i lack and so let that
person develop that and run with it
and produce an abundance and then trade
with me and i'll well that's that's the
well then that's the issue with regard
let's let's talk about the unfairness
issue it's like well
there's there's there doesn't look
to me like there's any systematic
centralized way of eradicating the
essential unfairness
because the unfairness and here's a
perverse little issue as well you know
amongst those who are tempted to engage
in critiques of our social institutions
let's say on the basis of their
hypothetical grounding in power
there's this mantra of diversity
okay so let's think about that for a
minute well diversity has to mean
something like difference in ability
because otherwise why would it be a good
and so then we could say well yeah you
want to have a diverse workforce because
well all things considered you need
people who are capable of doing a
variety of different things in case the
environment shifts on you okay so
diversity is a good but diversity is no
good at all unless there's comparative
advantage
and so
and i don't see how to get over the
equity hurdle with regards to
comparative advantage you know we want
equality of outcome well do we want
equality of outcome on all measures all
conceivable measures
well there's no comparative advantage
then anymore there's no diversity so
which is which is what we're going to
have we're going to have diversity or
equity because we can't have both
yeah you're right it is a weird paradox
and it's similar to how
men and women are exactly equal but
women are actually better at everything
like there's there's you know those
those two undercurrents in the standard
you know rhetoric coming out nowadays in
these in these culture wars so
so yeah i i'm agreeing with you that
it's
the yes the ostensible reason for why
you would want to promote diversity in
the workplace is that
because they
they will
argue with if you say oh no i should be
able to hire
um
the most qualified people and you know
to make the most profit and it's not
they'll argue they say oh no you're not
going to sacrifice profit you'll make
more money if you do what we're telling
you to because for the reasons you know
you're saying that you'll you'll have
have new perspectives when you're making
decisions and you'll know about you know
these people will know how this customer
base will react to your marketing and so
they're telling you that this is
actually the profitable decision if you
were like well and you know there well
the thing is is there's probably some
merit to that argument which is that you
know if you want to serve a population
you probably want representatives of the
population within your decision-making
purview but i would say the market
already rewards that
right intense right and and just to use
a different analogy it's like with in
the climate change debate i don't know
how much you follow that but it's a
similar thing where they want to pass
all these regulations like to give
business like to mandate
businesses have energy efficient uh you
know
insulation and do all these things
and so the right wing says no that's
going to impose costs and then they're
the left will say oh no actually they'll
save money and so i would always point
out well then you don't need to mandate
it just fax your data to the cfo of the
corporation and they'll do it on their
own and so likewise like you're saying
here if it really is true that this will
promote you know profit if this is a
this is a good move for the company it's
weird that we need to browbeat and
coerce everyone into doing it when by
assumption these are greedy capitalists
who do anything for a buck
except again apparently the one thing
they won't do is hire different well
especially given that you could you
could attain a comparative advantage by
doing so right
and i would say that's actually what's
happened i mean look if you think about
it historically
look at how quick women moved into the
workplace it's been let's say a hundred
years not that they weren't working like
mad before that because they certainly
were but
as soon as it became possible for women
to enter the workplace on the same terms
as men the workplace opened itself up to
them with incredible rapidity
and it's certainly a consequence of
taking advantage of the available power
so that system does work yeah and i so
and i should also mention too with a
bunch of this
you know if it sounds like we're being
real out of touch and like oh yeah it's
easy for you guys to say that given our
demographic characteristic there are a
lot of things like
injustices and but i would just say i
would attribute a lot of that to
um you know bad government schools and
minimum wage laws and things you know
things along those lines
met government measures that make it
hard for someone to start a business and
compete with the established firms so
there's a lot of things that explain
why in practice i think certain
relatively politically powerless groups
don't get a fair shake
but my point is it's not the pure market
we can also look we can also
be perfectly blunt in pointing out that
aberrations in the system might allow
for the maintenance of prejudice
that's not the issue the issue is
whether or not the bloody prejudice is
the central tendency because that's the
systemic racism claim i mean the fact
that the systems are error-prone is i
have no problem with that obviously
that's the case locally and sometimes
more widely
but that doesn't mean it's the central
tendency of the systems the central
tendencies ascendancy of the system
works against slavery for example not
for it
even though there are aberrations and
and the issue is what's central and
what's an aberration the claim that it's
power that's central is a totalizing
claim
and it's well and i would just add to
that though too it's
my i mean i'm as a complimentary point
as i'm just saying like jim crow laws
that you know the southern states that
had those they it was the government
forcing companies to do that why because
they would say oh
some of these private businesses are
just going to serve to blacks and whites
equally because they're you know they
don't understand the way our social
system work you know i mean so it's
it's funny that like a jim crow law is
cited as an example of the failures of
laissez faire capitalism and on its own
terms it was the government
overriding the prerogatives of business
owners to force them yeah because the
the money of any race is of equal value
right and all it would take is a few
diners and bus companies whoever said
believe that and then you know that this
the segregated system would would have a
problem would tend to break well that
did happen to some degree because black
businesses emerged to address exactly
that lack
now that didn't remove the prejudicial
laws but it did allow for the provision
of goods to the black community in those
particular circumstances so the market
found a way around the laws
at least with regards to the
distribution of resources right so it's
no justification for the laws it's
quite the contrary yeah so locate we we
need to talk about the business cycle so
um so and let's start by what it is and
why it's important right so what the
business cycle what people mean is the
fact that market economies tend to grow
over time you know the amount of goods
per hour per person goes up but it's not
a smooth periodic increase there's wild
ups and downs and in particular
there's periods where there's high
unemployment and then other times when
the labor market seems very tight and
people can get jobs easily
and so why where does that come from why
is that the case
and so the austrian explanation is
what happens is the banking system and
in modern times
under the aegis of central banks
um
pushes down interest rates below where
they should be so interest rates get
pushed to artificially low levels
that gives the wrong signal to the
entrepreneurs they start long-term
projects even though the public hasn't
saved enough to actually justify those
investments so it gives this false boom
period where everything seems prosperous
businesses are hiring
but there's not enough actual saving
to bring it to the finish line and at
some point the bank's chicken out
the central bank raises rates because
inflation's kicking up
and then
you know there's a crash
and so the austrian view
the
the the depression or the recession the
crisis is caused by the preceding boom
and the only way to get rid of that boom
bust cycle is to stop with this
alleged medicine of cutting interest
rates to stimulate spending that no
that's just sowing the seeds for the
next crash
so the price paid for central planning
that's not guided by market signals is
deviation from
the average essentially volatility
yes there's that but then also in the
long run i think the austrians would
argue because of the male and it's not
just
that oh it's the same average over the
100 years it's just more volatile but
that the average is lower than it
otherwise would be because
oh yes right so the productivity suffers
as well as in volatility increasing
right so
well okay i can also see an analogy
there with
the theories that i've been laying out
because you know my sense is is that
failure to react to a market signal so
to speak in the psychological world just
stores up catastrophe for later
so
yeah yeah so in the office so there you
go
the interest rate
has a role to play it serves a function
in in modern times when they say things
oh the because of slow consumer spending
the fed cut interest rates to try to
stim or are now you know because of the
corona virus the interest rates are very
low
in the m in most economic frameworks
that's like a good thing and oh the
question is just is that medicine going
to be enough to help and in the austrian
view no that's poison
that you're not doing us any favors by
making interest rates lower than they
should be because that's the wrong
signal just like you know if you put a
thermometer on us on a feverish
patient's head
and it's real high and you put some ice
on it to bring it down to 98.6
fahrenheit
that's you're not actually doing any
favors by by masking the signal no
that's that signal tells you something
and so if interest rates are supposed to
be six percent
even and how would interest rates be
calculated properly
in the absence of of determination by a
central source
just decentral just like
you know how is the price of oil
you know set we don't have a group of so
you just allow private lenders to set
the private interest rates private
lenders and borrowers where you know
they can work through commercial banks
and what but it's decentralized i mean
if you think about it's weird
in the ostensibly free market capitalist
u.s
there's a group of people who tell us
what interest rates are and they
periodically okay so why why is that
well
the official i know that's a terrible
complicated question but i'd still i
don't know the answer to it it is odd so
it's
the price of money is is centrally
planned
right and actually because interest is
the price of money essentially or the
price of borrowing it yeah the um yes
it's funny uh i think was it i think it
was jon stewart um you know the daily
show guy he had alan greenspan on if i
hope i'm not mixing up the this is the
spirit of this is correct and he asked
him that once he said you know we have a
free market economy right
why do we have a group of central
playing with it and you know greenspan
kind of gave some obfuscation answer but
so
the official reason people would give is
they say oh before
central banks in the u.s there were
these panics
you know and there was wild deflationary
you know there was ups and downs and
then the fed was supposed to be formed
to be a lender of last resort to provide
stability
so even if that were true on its own
terms well no the great depression
happened on the fed's watch the
great recession happened on the fed's
watch other empirical measures there was
more volatility post-fed than pre-fed
so even on its own terms that didn't
the more cynical people would say well
you know it's a group of bankers and
they were instrumental in you know the
federal reserve act and getting that
thing established and it's an
institution that
provides liquidity and bails out bankers
when they get into trouble and so you
know what's the mystery there that
that's why it happens so you know that's
the cynical interpretation
and which interpretation do you do you
favor i mean i we don't want to be
cynical about it right and it's always
i'm always leery of conversations that
point to they you know because
these huge problems they're all our
problems right there are problems man so
we have this central banking authority
and we decided at some point that that
was a good idea
and
i cynical theories tend to be incomplete
at best in my view
i mean
what's the cost
in your view or the view of the austrian
school of having
the central
interest rate planned in this manner
it's the business cycle that's that's
the that's the issue is that
it's not informed properly the decisions
right that
by periodically pushing interest rates
below what they should be
you know what's the just in pure cause
and effect what's the what's the problem
with that is when it comes to interest
rates in particular it causes this
artificial boom period that necessarily
must end in a bust and as you say over
the course of the cycle resources are
used inefficiently so that when the
whole thing's said and done with people
are poorer than they otherwise would
have been had interest rates been set in
a true market all along
so that's you know the cost of doing
that besides that there's redistributive
things as well that if you have this
engine of inflation where in a sense
in modern times the central bank can
literally just create money
electronically
that's an avenue to corruption like
right now the federal reserve is buying
private sector bonds they started doing
that you know in the wake of the
coronavirus panic
so you know are they doing that purely
on the merits or is there some
you know
things going on beside behind the scenes
as to which companies bonds get
purchased and don't so it's with all
this stuff yes there's different
motivations but
um i i yeah well sometimes it's not
merely is there corruption but you know
is there sufficient
transparency so that conspiracy theories
of corruption stay
up
what
less popular that's a problem right when
these decisions are being made even if
they're not actually corrupt they
destroy trust in public institutions
because they're not transparent and
there is room for corruption right so so
yeah what the austrians can say is
regardless of where the motivations are
but the fact is that yes centrally
planning prices and you know we know
outright central planning of all prices
doesn't work that's you know the
collapse of socialism we can just see
empirically that doesn't work and then
the austrians i think are being
consistent and saying so why are we
centrally planning money and banking
you know if central bank doesn't work
elsewhere let me close this
then
what do you this is a bit of a left
field question but i've talked to some
people recently about bitcoin so i'm
going to ask you about it
it's sort of the ultimate decentralized
economics
any any
opinions about bitcoin what do you think
about this idea of taking the monetary
system out of the even the hypothetical
control of centralized institutions and
and you know regardless in some sense of
the specific merits of bitcoin it's it's
a revolutionary idea
in some sense
what what do you think about it
right so i think it's a fascinating case
study and i think it took a lot of us
economists by surprise
i think if you had asked me
before it was you know in 2007 could
something like bitcoin exist i think i
would have predicted well no because how
would it get off the ground like why
would people accept it it just it seems
like it's a circular problem like how
would anyone know what it was worth
and how it did get off the ground is at
first it was almost free like it was you
know somebody gave a bunch for two
pizzas or something and then it just
kind of bootstrapped so that's how they
got around that problem i would say
which you know i didn't think of or i
wouldn't have thought of if you'd asked
me ahead of time so right although it's
a classic free market
you know why not invest in it if it's
pennies to the dollar so to speak
because there's some potential upside
right and so yeah the market took care
of that in some sense yeah so i
so what you know the intellectual
problem they saw because hayek had a
famous essay
where he was arguing
for so what he said is you know free
free market types have tended to focus
on commodity money like gold and silver
coins and contrast it with fiat money
like government paper because
historically the government paper would
crash and you know the the hard money
the gold and silver was sound stable
currency
but hayek said maybe that's wrong maybe
just because historically
fiat
paper money has been issued by
governments what if you had private
firms that could issue name brand
currency that was just paper
but you know as a private company so you
had name brand recognition and they
would you know compete with each other
so in other words to privatize central
banking let's call it
and so he had a whole essay on that and
but even there the problem was you had
to trust
you know the reputation or the the the
honesty integrity of the issuer of
whatever those paper notes were so i
think the virtue of bitcoin is
they you know satoshi figured out a way
to um
make it so that there's a sense in which
the system
keeps track of itself and there's no one
in charge of it you know it's completely
distributed right and so and how do you
safely spend money and solve that
problem to accurately transfer funds if
nobody's in charge of this of the whole
ledger so that was like the intellectual
masterpiece in terms of what he did and
then now so that's what's new about it
and and yes it's now that it's off the
ground yeah
to answer your question yeah there's a
growing number of people who are
austrian enthusiasts who are saying
bitcoin or cryptocurrency in general is
great um i'll say for sure
i like it because it shows the public
that you could have privately created
money just like with with uber and lyft
to me that's the easiest way to get the
public to see you don't need to have
government medallions for taxi cabs
because before uber and lyft people
might have just said oh no it's for
safety you can't just have a free market
and
in rides because the cabbie might shoot
you or you know rob you at gunpoint or
something or you know be driving and
that didn't happen well no no ebay is
interesting that way too you know
because ebay to me is an absolute
miracle i mean i know it's it's a less
robust platform than it once was but i
mean it was free enterprise at its
most wildly
unregulated and it produced this
incredible explosion of value because
people could trade frozen capital very
you know your junk in your basement was
now worth something to someone and
the cynics said well you know i'll send
you broken junk and you'll pay me with a
check that'll bounce and that didn't
happen you know they put in place
brokers uh escrow agents to begin with
not ebay itself but they were available
so that you could
insure your transaction and what
happened was the bulk of the
transactions were so honest like 99
percent of them are 90 98.5 percent of
them that the escrow agents weren't
necessary
so which was extremely interesting in in
my estimation and uber and lyft are are
very interesting examples of that as
well because they were they seemed to be
at least as safe
as taxis in my experience the uber and
lyft cars are usually in better shape
than taxi cabs and they're much cheaper
and generally it's a more pleasant
experience yeah and it's cheaper and it
provides instant or did provide instant
employment to people which was a real
miracle in my estimation it's like you
were unemployed but you had access to a
car it's like you had a job right then
and there
remarkable remarks so just so i think
the average person
could understand the possibility of oh
yeah maybe we don't need the government
to have a cartel operation with taxi
cabs in the name of protecting the
public from unscrupulous drivers
likewise i think with cryptocurrency
people seeing that and seeing how it
works and you know realizing oh yeah
maybe it's not it shouldn't we shouldn't
just take it for granted that oh clearly
the government provides courts and
police and money obviously the
government has to be in charge of
issuing money because otherwise that to
me that's what one of the virtues of you
know cryptocurrency is is that people
can at least see an example of something
that was obviously had nothing to do
with the political system
yeah well it does definitely seem to be
a currency whose fundamental underlying
philosophy is in line with the
fundamental underlying philosophy of the
austrian school of of
economics certain uh the only reason i'm
gonna stop is i just do want to
acknowledge it there
some austrians are divided on that so
some are really okay they love commodity
money and they think no gold and silver
and they think bitcoin like no that
makes no sense that's crazy that's just
like a big bubble
so
i don't endorse that right but i do want
to just say that that that their
austrians are divided yeah well i guess
the i guess the affinity is that it's a
distributed currency
um it it that hypothetically
capitalizes on distributed computation
it's not under the control of any
centralized bureaucracy whether or not
it's the proper solution to that problem
i i yeah so there's room for
intelligence
any austrian you know norm is going to
say go ahead and do what you want you
don't want to shut it down obviously
like go ahead and do it if you want to
i'm just you know i personally wouldn't
invest it like that would be their view
right and you're right the the bitcoin
enthusiast though they would say there's
a sense in which it's even harder than
gold because you know hits the 21
million and that's it whereas in
principle
we could go get an asteroid that has a
bunch of gold so maybe gold actually
wouldn't be the best money for the next
200 years because of some discovery or
some you know innovation in chemistry
where they can just make gold pretty
cheaply out of sea water for example
whereas bitcoin just its very nature
mathematically it's got a fixed limit
and so there's a sense in which that's
really hard if if it were to become
money
all right well i think that's probably a
good place to stop um
i've been speaking with dr robert murphy
this is his book
choice cooperation enterprise and human
action and today we talked about the
austrian school of economics and many
other things and thank you very much it
was very educational as far as i was
concerned i i'm much more
solid in my understanding of perhaps
economics in general not that i know
anything about it yet but that was very
helpful and
i appreciate you taking the time to
speak with me and wish you luck with
your book and um
anything else you'd like to add before
we close up oh i mean i would just uh
thank you for this opportunity to talk
with you and uh i was very excited to do
so i just want to mention i've been
watching a lot of your lectures and i'm
a big fan of your work and appreciate
what you've been doing
no thank you thank you very much all
right
[Music]
you